foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
mic check mic check mic check
retro wrecking sword live
one night early folks one night early
proud Slytherin
what you talking about Ryan what you
talking about what you talk about Ryan
oh man yeah I realized
I realized like The Moment I Saw James's
tweet today
oh wait
I need to stream today too
because I'm gonna be traveling tomorrow
after work
all right let's switch up let's try try
a different
playlist here
[Music]
check check there we go there we go yeah
I don't know why the uh the sound on the
transitions just randomly stop working
just
randomly stopped working one day
so yeah but I see that uh stream
elements is here and working so that's
good
[Music]
stream Elms I mean stream elements is
early tonight Nico even working for Nico
look at that
traveling you say hinted oh no no no
it's uh so for those of us in the US
Thanksgiving holiday is coming up
so yeah I'm actually taking off work
Wednesday Thursday Friday we get off
Thursday anyway
then I'm taking off the Wednesday Friday
and my my kids are out of school too so
they go tomorrow and then they're out
for the rest of the week
so yeah and then my wife I've mentioned
I think before on stream she's a nurse
so she has to work kind of weird
oh my gosh I just turned the volume up
really loud when I when I turned my head
like that a little volume slider
but uh yeah so she actually has to work
on Thanksgiving Day so that's why we're
going down visit with some family just a
little bit early this year
ah
had a talk behind the scenes
I mean I couldn't believe it I saw Elwyn
was using the spoiler one early and then
I saw you throw out the Discord one so
that's awesome
but yeah guys welcome thank you all so
much for being here for another
weekly stream of retro raconteur live
uh I mean guys like November is almost
complete and I didn't I mean we're
getting so close at this point like I
didn't want to miss a stream
there's Elwyn with the two months
how is it has it only been two months
elwin feels like so much longer hey I've
been here two months now thanks retro
for allowing me to be part of this great
Community thank you Ellen for all that
you bring to the community guys elwin a
mod here on the YouTube and then also
over in the Discord as well
can't believe it's only been two months
that's crazy to me it feels like much
longer and then our boy volte is back
once again oh no it's happening again
JK lol one just wanted to say hi won't
Spain with super chats again for now
laughs volte welcome back and volte
thank you so much even for joining us
here on the Monday night I know it was
kind of short notice so I figure we
might have some people showing up
tomorrow being like where's the live
stream so that was my fault I should
have got it out a little bit earlier the
notice on that but
hold up hold up
two months happy two months y'all are
wonderful wish I could stay the whole
stream grateful to be a part of this
amazing Community Christy thank you I'm
so glad you're a part of the community
as well all good if you can't stay the
whole time and then Elwyn immediately
after oh wait this was after volte Elwyn
gifted out five tier one memberships so
five of you may see your name pop up
sometimes stream elements is working on
the commands tonight but on the alerts I
don't know I don't know we'll wait and
see we'll wait and see I saw it pop up
initially
you know what I actually should be able
to
pause alert skip alert
what if I do this right here and I say
like refresh alert
oh but my little picture's gone
oh
dude I switched away I've told the story
way too many times but I think I'm just
gonna have to go back to stream labs for
the alerts although it could be a
YouTube thing as well like I know I
think Jay I'm pretty sure James uses
stream labs
and then we've got Dylan with the four
months as well yo smash that like button
for our favorite dad who loves games and
the stories they tell what's up Dylan
thank you so much for the four months
Dylan another moderator here and then we
had the two months in there from
Stargazer Tim
what is up my friend
oh wait wait wait what just what's
popping up now what's popping up now
volte okay wait he's way behind oh no
that
it's not way behind that's a new super
chat from Bolt so the super chats are
working that's good volte it's all good
man I'm not worried
super chats are indeed working but yeah
it was like the memberships took them a
little bit longer to pop up two months
it only seems like around 60 60 days
Stargazer Tim yo while you're here let
me try to mod
let me try to mod Stargazer Tim as well
because Stargazer Tim is also a mod over
in the Discord and I told him I said
next time you're here
remind me to moderate you so let's see
if that works Stargazer Tim is now a
moderator for your channel there you go
Tim you got all the powers now all the
powers of the moderator are now in your
hands
but guys even though they didn't pop up
five of you just got a gifted membership
from Elwyn actually you know what I
think I can maybe I can force them to
pop up right here watch this watch this
watch this
and we also got Olimar one month as a
member yay all of our 92 my friend
welcome thank you so much Olimar all
right let's see if this works I think I
can trigger oh each of elwin's gifted
Subs you guys can see
there we go all right so Ryan with a
gifted
and we wait for that one to go away
all right there we go
we got Kratos Raptor with a gifted
you know what while that's up let me see
if I can fix the uh
two
it's all wrong
it's all wrong
why why is it not working
and then we got
[Music]
soundtrack with a gift of membership
yo and then Casey Lawrence with a five
dollar Super Chat Casey thank you so
much is this LGBT plus an Autism Safe
Community also hope this helps with
holiday shopping too Casey thank you so
much for the Super Chat and supporting
what we do here absolutely we we are
welcoming to all here
welcoming to all this is a positive
vibes community
so uh you were you are very much welcome
here and thank you for uh
sharing some love with the stream
definitely helps with the holiday
shopping yeah lots of lots of holiday
shopping coming up for me and the family
although we recently started doing
something a few years ago
my hands are like ice right now they are
so cold and I forgot my little gloves in
here it's all good
but um
so yeah a few years ago like I have we
have two kids
my middle sister has three kids and then
my youngest sister just had her second
kid and we got to the point where we
were like because we were still buying
stuff for each other and we said okay
this is kind of crazy let's let's switch
this up let's do something different and
we don't have to uh we don't have to buy
for everybody anymore and so we started
what we did is we draw a name so it's
kind of like a
sort of like a dirty Santa but I mean we
get a we get wait what's that one called
is that like the white white elephant
there's just there's a name for it right
like you draw anyway Secret Santa
I think that's it
so we draw each draw a name and then we
like set a limit this is how much we're
gonna spend and then we of course we
still buy for all the kids how are you
welcome wait I think are alerts working
now Carlos with a 9.99 Super Chat as
well retro Records who are my fellow
Gryffindor Carlos welcome back good to
see you Carlos and thank you so much for
that Super Chat indeed fellow Gryffindor
yo are we at 100 likes yet are we at 100
likes Casey Lawrence renewed their tier
one membership as well nice let's go and
then we just have like a bunch of
subscribers coming in back to back to
back Troy Tammy TXS thank you all for
subscribing to the channel and then
unbox Mania renewing their membership as
well
so guys thank you all for the new
members and if you got gifted a
membership make sure you thank elwin as
well for the gift of membership what do
you get here on YouTube when you are a
member you get uh some special emoji
that you can use in the chat you get
discount on our merch which we just
launched some brand new merch just in
time for the holidays uh you just go to
Retro wreckingtour.com click on merch
and find it and then um you also get as
we found out a couple streams ago you
were not subject to slow mode when you
remember so I didn't know that we
discovered that together you're not
subject to slow mode uh and then you
have a special Community section of our
YouTube page as well where sometimes
I'll post things like polls for feedback
on upcoming videos or ideas that I have
all sorts of stuff like that
so thank you all so much for your
support of the channel
if you're a YouTube member on uh oh yeah
the special prefect role as Rel as as
well as well Nico that's right
Nico getting the merch dude I I just
can't believe
at least this much of stream elements is
working okay hold on I was logged in
here because I want to see if I can fix
the uh
okay so I'm on the full cam screen right
now
so we got a lot to talk about dude we
got a lot to talk about ASMR coming up
this week I'm guessing it's going to be
tomorrow
I mean they could release it on
Thanksgiving I know outside the U.S you
all don't really celebrate Thanksgiving
but
we um lowercase Logan with a super chat
a retro Happy Thanksgiving same to you
as well Logan I I've got to do something
about this
I told you guys I changed my setup a lot
I've I've kept this longer than any
other setup but there's one big thing
that's bothering me
and it's I don't know if you guys
probably can't tell because it looks
like I'm at an angle but what I'm trying
to read the chat
I'm staring right in to the to the arm
of this mic so that's why I'm always
kind of like this a little bit
uh let's see lowercase Logan said okay
wait that's hold on that's a little bit
better right there then we can kind of
just angle oh wait wait okay I think
we're good
hope you have a wonderful time with your
family shout out Noob Alicia and Nico
and then waliamas subscribing to the
channel as well there's Casey just
joined yo
AC with another Super Chat and I think
she joined as well
been looking for an inclusive Harry
Potter Community since 2019.
glad I finally found one hey there's uh
I don't know if you've checked out James
of expecto go
another great Hogwarts Legacy content
creator he and Sue just did their live
stream
a couple hours ago normally James and I
don't go on the same day he does
Wizarding Wednesday I do
I haven't come up with a clever name for
it yet retro record Tour live
on Tuesdays and then um yeah James is or
James and Sue are great as well
and then um I'm trying to think of
everyone else who does live streams but
but yeah there's a lot of good Hogwarts
Legacy content creators but I think
James and I are the only two who kind of
do regular I know podcast now does like
occasional streams he's been
interviewing a lot of Hogwarts Legacy
content creators again
so I know we interviewed James and I
think he's got Ben coming up Ben snow
coming up tomorrow
Story Time with retro Couture what's up
Jay Rossi
[Music]
not losing more in-house points oh no
new what happened
what happened noob
keep donating so we never get to that
topics
dude right there's Ryan last name with a
two dollar Super Chat didn't even have a
message but I saw your message in chat
Ryan about not um
about keep donating so I don't get to
the topics I can't even get to the
little um
see I've already forgotten I forgot what
I was even doing here okay it was
something to do with alerts yes alerts
on the memberships I think okay so let's
go into alerts here
and we're going to go into settings
member alert so it looks like the
picture is broken why would that be
broken
that should not be broken
all right let's just change the image
I'm gonna submit it again
and then we'll save
all right now I'm gonna emulate
a membership right here real quick so
this is not gonna be a real one let's
see if it works
oh gosh how are you welcome to it's
double sound okay that's working that's
working all right now let me go back to
elwin's gifteds
and let me hit this right here
it didn't work
is it different because it's gifted
oh it it is I bet but I think I don't
think we've ever had this problem before
guys if you're new here welcome to Retro
wrecking Tour live this at the beginning
is always a little bit crazy
we're all just still settling in we
haven't got to the topics yet don't
worry I always have people coming in
like an hour late did you miss anything
no no not yet
you haven't missed anything
all right so
I need to go back here
nope not that far stream elements not
that far back
all right they were gonna go back here
then we're gonna go to alerts
and then we're gonna go to there is
there is not one for gifted
there's
there's not one for gifteds
oh wait membership gift when variation
is a gift
hold up hold up hold up
okay okay let's set the image for this
I'm just going to use the same image
because I mean come on dude gifted
membership same as membership they're
all equal in my eyes
wait
wait
all right
no I don't want that image that was who
was that that was uh
that was Casey with another Super Jack
Casey going crazy with the super chats
right now might join the Discord next
month shy and trying to get past it oh
don't be shy I mean you could be shy you
can just don't join the Discord and you
don't have to say a whole lot
and to all I realize there's so many
people like you think about how many
active Chatters I feel like we have
quite a few active chatters
and yet there are still so many people
who are just lurkers which is which is
totally fine you know totally fine
but it always surprises me to really
think about you know there's there's
probably way more
lurkers than there are active chatters
so to the lurkers out there shout out to
you
all good all good don't feel like you
have to uh chat but you're more than
welcome if you want to
all right let me try to save this now if
this doesn't work then this is it
[Music]
boom
boom look at that and Ellen even gets
like a special color and dude the
letters are kind of freaking me out
we'll fix that later but they're
bouncing
it's all good it's all good the sound
effects not right but we at least got it
so it's not a little
broken image that's popping up there
oh guys all right let's get to the part
of the stream where we shout out
everyone who is here and hanging out uh
exclamation point Discord Carl
and it should pop up there in the Stream
all right so
see I don't think this is accurate this
little thing that shows participants
because I there are more people in here
chatting than than names that were
showed up there
all right let's say Not Top chat I want
live chat I want everybody and then I
want to see participants yeah they're
way more participants than that you're
wrong you're wrong YouTube
you're wrong I know you are all right
but anyway we're gonna shout out to
people that are showing up here
and if I miss you I'll try to get you in
the chat so here tonight
on a Monday edition of retroactive Tour
live we have Bella DD Channel member
Boneyard Grim is here Brittany is that
Eli or Brittany l e l l yeah darkest
demon Dustin Quest elwin feathers Go
Ninja Go Jay Rossi all of those right
there channel members Joseph Davidson is
here JP raven fire Casey Lawrence new
channel member I don't think your
channel membership popped up for some
reason Casey we got we got the super
chats Channel memberships oh wait there
it is there it is there it is you know
what if I didn't if I didn't call it out
when it pops up we're just gonna do that
again
all right nearly headless Nick we only
need one of you so closing out the other
one
uh let's see feathers oh yeah we got
feathers Gabe is here also go ninja go J
Rossi Jose Davidson got you then we got
JP raven fire Casey Lawrence both
channel members uh kalala kilala is here
crin Alexia Malcolm Carrick is here then
we got Noob and Nico in the House
nightly nerds shout out to Nightly nerd
fellow Hogwarts Legacy content creator
uh Professor Abbott here hanging out as
well I saw Professor Abbott in I believe
it was Wizard PhD stream earlier today
radar in the house Ryan Kingsbury as
well as Ryan last name both channel
members also Professor Abbott Noob and
Nico channel members sassy sis in the
house tonight uh satin satin Hal
Stargazer Tim Channel member and
moderator here Steven is here stream
elements is here and actually
doing their job the night stream
elements thanks so much for being here
appreciate it uh the Carl entry Tim
Brewster Ultra Blue Junior Ultra Blue
always see your comments on YouTube
videos thank you so much for all the
support uh Vol USA X drecky and then oh
it's your boy James expecto go Bringing
you guys the latest and greatest
I see him in the chat list I don't know
if he said anything in the chat yet let
me go back to the chat now and I'll be
able to tell you
if my chat my chat just it just you know
what it OBS man it died
all right hold on let me see if I can
bring you guys back bring you guys back
all right I would like to see the chat
there you guys are oh you're all so
beautiful you're so beautiful there
all the names in the chat
man I tell you it's technology dude
technology
sometimes it just doesn't work the way
you want it to
all right so if I missed you I'll try to
catch you guys in the chat
nightly nerd and expecto go dude we got
some we got two other Hogwarts Legacy
content creators here in the house
watch wizard PhD expect to go in retro
right all in one
well I was telling James when I first
started doing this I was like
we're all we were all positioned on
different days I think wizard PhD might
stream
she does quite a few streams so
yeah there's there might be some overlap
there but yeah there was like a time
where we were on a pretty solid streak
of you could watch a hog a new Hogwarts
Legacy Creator every day of the week
every day of the week
all right guys we're gonna shift over
into our next scene
and talk about all the news of which
there has been a lot
all right I mentioned the uh
it's it's so funny how sometimes with
streams you have things exactly the way
they have been and then they just they
just decide to stop working there's like
an update or something behind the scenes
on one program
so get this one out this is this is a
crazy one
so I have stream elements as I mentioned
a couple times with you guys I use OBS
and there's like this little uh this
little tool that integrates stream
elements in OBS so when I first found
this I was like oh this is brilliant
because I see my chat on one side here
and then I see the activity feed on the
right side
so all that stuff that I was triggering
again when elwyn's gifted memberships
didn't pop up correctly
I was triggering those again
through the uh through this little
activity feed thing
all that's working great but then in the
chat over here on the left
it won't let me chat with you guys
because it says it's in subscribers only
mode
and so somehow it's like OBS or stream
elements is somehow logged out of my
account
and so it's detecting me as not a member
even though I'm live on my own channel
it's pretty funny I'll here's another
funny thing about YouTube I've always
thought it was hilarious that you uh you
have to watch ads on your own videos
Believe It or Not guys
ads on your own videos
it always cracks me up I'm like okay so
are they am I actually like paying
myself somehow for this
yeah it's interesting
oh but man good to see James here good
to see nightly nerd here
uh so James was a guest last week on the
stream guys if you didn't check out man
I'm really not feeling any of these uh
feeling any of these tonight
if you guys are wondering why I'm I'm
being very very careful with the music
for any of you who have tried to go back
and watch some of our vods you may
notice some really strange editing
anybody in the replay squad on this one
you'll be happy to see that this one
well I shouldn't say for sure fingers
crossed this one should play through
without any edits so that is not me
trying to go back and hide anything
uh what it is is the YouTube copyright
system is Auto detecting some of the
music that I'm using which I every music
that I ever play on stream I'm under the
assumption that it's copyright free and
yet some still keeps getting flagged
some of it had things where they say hey
if you um email this address we will
whitelist your channel and then you can
use it I've done that and never heard
back so the past couple weeks I'm just
sticking to things that I know are 100
sure copyright free
so that's what I'm doing here but man I
just can't find any that I'm uh
the sounds of any of these let me go
back to
go back to this other playlist
and I'm also going to turn it down a
little bit
live stream was great as always yeah I I
I'm glad you guys thought so I I
definitely want to have James on again
and we might just have to do it on a
night other than Tuesday or we might
have to do it
earlier than my usual stream time
because
James we only had him for an hour
and he and I could have talked a lot
longer
a lot longer for sure Chris huff and
puff first retro live stream let's go
hey Chris
thank you so much good to see you here
shout out to the Ryan dude we have a we
have multiple Ryan's and we have
multiple Logans in every stream
and so I kind of I don't know how much
we need to talk about the regular the uh
because I know wizard PhD did a big
conversation on it and expecto go did a
big conversation on it so let's catch
you guys up if you haven't
just in case because maybe I feel like a
lot of you watch their streams too but
if you haven't
I want to catch you all up on the news
so first of all
oh wait I thought this was the ASMR I
thought it was posted I was like what I
missed it
so that was the first thing I was going
to talk about though is um oh they
didn't even actually post this on the
main account it was Chandler so let's go
back to Chandler first here
bench strife
all right so Chandler posted
right here
so this was November 18th 12 35 PM
Eastern Time
yo look in the comments there our boy
Dylan
our boy Dylan like making sure
he's like I don't want James retro or
podcast now to miss this
appreciate the tag Dylan appreciate the
tag so Chandler said keeping busy
working on a lot of things the sounds of
a crisp autumn wind and crunchy falling
leaves are coming next week because I
love this community though how about a
sneak peek pulled this screenshot from
one of Andrew's capture so
I meant to reply to this and be like uh
so photo mode confirmed
photo mode confirmed actually you know
what let's just do that right now
so
what I'm taking from this aside from the
obvious is
photo mode
confirmed
I see I feel like Photo mode that's one
of those things surely they can uh
that's not like it's not spoiling
anything you know definitely let us know
that before launch
definitely let us know that before
launch Chandler
all right so just a glorious shot as I
think all the outdoor stuff in Hogwarts
Legacy has looked spectacular this shot
right here the moment I saw it I thought
about Deathly Hallows and Harry Ron and
Hermione you know camping out in the
forest and the snatchers and all those
scenes
obviously not showing a lot here we can
see there's some sort of structure over
here on the left but that ASMR is coming
this week now as I was about to say
earlier
I guess it could really be
so for those of you outside the US
Thanksgiving is a really big holiday
here and then also which is Thursday and
then also Black Friday is like the
I think it might still be the biggest
shopping day of the year in the US for
holiday shopping season
so both of those are kind of like even
Black Friday is almost considered like
its own kind of holiday so I I wouldn't
expect that they'll release it on either
of those days unless I mean it could be
like a you know all that stuff is a set
set it and leave it right they can
schedule a post
but I could I could see it hitting
earlier I could see it hitting tomorrow
or Wednesday even
because tomorrow would be Tuesday the
22nd or Wednesday the 23rd
and then they'll probably want to at
least see
you know you do want to be in the office
or at least close to a computer where
you can you know monitor make sure
everything goes up correctly because on
the scheduling things like HootSuite
sometimes things can go wrong not
published when they're supposed to
so yeah I'm thinking maybe tomorrow
James thinks tomorrow or Friday
doesn't PS5 have a built-in photo mode
steam as well um
so JP the difference in like a dedicated
photo mode so what the PS5 has is like a
share button
and I'm not as familiar with it on PC
but I assume it's somewhat similar to
that
Dylan with the ten dollar Super Chat
Dylan says what's your favorite
Thanksgiving item turkey taters
cranberries pie Etc
[Music]
okay I'll let I'll let you guys actually
you know what that's a good uh
that's a good poll
that's a good poll
let's do that as our as our poll right
now
all right so start a poll
favorite
Thanksgiving and if you don't celebrate
Thanksgiving just pick your favorite
food of this
favorite Thanksgiving menu item
all right so
option one turkey and let's let's throw
ham in there too I'm gonna say turkey
slash ham
oh man only four options that's just not
enough okay dressing slash some people
call it stuffing
all right and then oh dude yeah we're
definitely not gonna have enough room
let's say pumpkin pie for the last one
and then I'm gonna say for sides I'm
gonna say things like um
dude my family we love some macaroni and
cheese
macaroni and cheese
this could be your starch Macaroni and
Cheese slash
um some form of potatoes
and actually I'm just gonna everybody's
gonna say dessert if I say I was gonna
say pumpkin pie slash dessert but then
everybody would say dessert because some
people don't like pumpkin pie
see we just need we need more options
here but I'm gonna ask you guys that and
we'll come back to it in a second
we'll come back to it here in a second
wish you did mac and cheese feathers oh
man I love mac and cheese is just a
staple around our house
but then around I mean Thanksgiving we
still we we still always have it around
Thanksgiving too
all right so
what were we talking about
what are we talking about I think we
were talking about the release of the oh
photo mode photo mode photo mode
and it's exactly what uh Nick just said
there yeah so PS5 is just like a
screenshot so
some games have a what they most games
nowadays have a built-in photo mode and
so what that means is that you can not
just pause the game because there's a
big difference when you pause the game
you may still have HUD elements that are
still showing up you may still have
um various things on the menu that are
showing
however a true photo mode which actually
one of my recent tweets I can show you
guys a true photo mode is not just the
pause menu it will take you into a
separate mode
to where you can completely it's no HUD
elements
but it's not just stuck on that screen
you can move the camera around
you can change different lighting
effects um a lot of them like ghost of
tsushima has where you can change the
time of day you can change the weather
so imagine being able to go to a scene
in Hogwarts Legacy an outside shot of
the castle and say
oh wow I love this shot but I want let
me just like change the lighting here a
little bit let me make it at night
instead that's the difference between a
photo mode so like I took these in God
of War so this is 2018. so I don't know
how well it's going to show up on stream
um
but like I actually this was a shot an
in-game shot I paused the game and then
I kind of move the camera here so the
lighting that was already set up all I
really changed on this one is I kind of
shifted the positioning of it
uh this one right here so this is one of
the NPCs in God of War
and so like see I don't you can even
remove like like Kratos or the main
character you can like take the main
character out of the shot if you just
want a shot of the scenery so here
obviously no Kratos and then I just zoom
in
frame the shot
and then I have like Oh I thought this
one was so cool that was actually in I
think that one was in a cut scene though
and I just snapped a quick shot but this
game like all the cutscenes are rendered
in engine anyway so it all looks it's
all the same and then oh that one's so
good dude
that was so good
so yeah every time I bring up photo mode
and why I want a photo mode so bad
that's why
that's why I want a photo mode
is because everything they have showed
about the
everything like without the environment
of Hogwarts Legacy looks phenomenal I
feel like anybody critiquing Hogwarts
Legacy in terms of Graphics it's usually
to do with like the animations of the
characters
um which I I understand but the like the
scenery oh everything looks so good
it looks so good Hanson says I love
these live streams bro it's been so long
since I watched a small Creator stream
that I genuinely enjoy Hanson wow thank
you so much
yeah I've I've just been saying man we
just got to enjoy this journey because
after the game comes out I mean who
knows what's gonna happen I expect some
of you will stick around but truth be
told a lot of people will move on and I
get that I understand that I mean
they're they're here for for this game
for following news on it but yeah it
really is it's a it's a special time
very special time
all dude we're at 86 likes I got a
surprise for you guys if we if we hit
100 likes I got a surprise for you guys
tonight
you know it's it's not as cool as a
pirate like James does but I do have I
do have a little surprise
all right let's see if we can get it up
to 100.
so yeah when you like to stream it just
helps uh helps YouTube boost it out so
other people can uh can find it
so yeah we got this hitting this week at
some point sadly I will be let's see
I'll be back in town
trying to figure out when I'll be back
in town
probably late Friday
but I may have time to get a video out
by Saturday we'll just have to see
I really haven't done a lot of huge
breakdown videos on the ASMR anyway
on any of the previous ones I I love
looking at them but it's just like
I'll let James handle James and a wife
wants a wizard I can't handle the
breakdowns
I still gotta get my video out on the
all the secrets and details which by the
way Ben snow had an awesome video
on the uh secrets and details from the
gameplay showcase so
if you haven't checked his out
definitely check that out all right so
that was the first tweet I wanted to
talk about
so we got that expected to hit this week
any any day now this week
and I'm draws what's up family draws
family draws what the heck I got
Thanksgiving on my mind fandom draws
oven roasted potato stuffed with mac and
cheese
that sounds tasty turkey typical Puerto
Rican rice and
I don't know how how to pronounce that
other word Professor Abbott cranberry
don't know how to pronounce that word
with rum
pumpkin
pie
is that what you mean
greens potato salad love it all dark
steam my family has a secret family
recipe for stewed tomatoes ah nice which
see I love that dude like everybody has
their own little uh
their own little thing that you're like
the way my family makes dressing or
stuffing is is very very different from
most of the
stuffings that I had it's my
grandmother's I think it's my
grandmother's recipe
and it's more like most of the stuffing
that I always eat is is kind of like
very thick and dry but this is not at
all this is this is like
the opposite of that basically but still
kind of has a similar taste it's way
more like a like a dressing that you
would eat
on top of your turkey that's how I love
to eat it is like I I have it on top of
the turkey
go ninja go I'm torn my grandfather does
a few different turkey's hams my mom
does restaurant amazing quality mashed
potatoes oh see you guys are getting me
yeah exactly feathers getting me hungry
and ready for uh for Thanksgiving
Witcher 3 is a good example of photo
mode as well
oh yeah I mean it's almost like a staple
in in modern games now
almost like a staple by the way I saw
somebody earlier asking about
um
if I am a Hufflepuff no I'm a Gryffindor
oh oh wait wait wait wait wait
all right hold on hold on hold on let's
see
we're gonna turn off the webcam for a
second here
because we're we're over 100 likes my
chat is informing me
all right
all right so you guys were asking
you were asking about the uh the house
you were saying is is retro is retro a
Hufflepuff no retro is not a Hufflepuff
better be
Gryffindor
I'm a Gryffindor chat Gryffindor and
yeah you can see we have a uh a very
special guest who is who has joined us
here tonight
let's see did I put it on backwards it's
kind of hard to see the mouth
there we go there we go you can see but
what I love about this one it's actually
a feathers feathers with the perfect
reaction right there
feathers had the perfect reaction
see I'm like should I should I tie this
underneath here
no so this this is a preview of things
to come you guys preview of things to
come
so my wife loves decorating for for the
holidays for Christmas she she loves it
she loves it and I'm always I'm not like
a scrooge but I'm definitely a bit of a
it's like it's such a hassle
like our house doesn't have a lot of
storage space
and so every year and my son I mean we
love decorating for our kids because our
kids love it they get real into it of
course
and
she
um my my biggest issue is like storage
our house is so limited on storage and I
just refuse to buy like a storage unit I
think it's such a waste of money I think
we just have to uh better
we just need to get rid of more stuff is
my solution
but I made a comment the other day I
said you know what we need to
I already have like the decoration thing
going over here it's like for the
holidays I need like a little tree right
here a little tree
and we can decorate it with
gaming Hogwarts Harry Potter all the
above related ornaments
and so she's like man that's all I had
to say that's all I had to say she took
it she she ran with it she's already
bought the tree so I think we'll start
with um let's see I might
yeah I feel like after Thanksgiving
I feel like after Thanksgiving was when
you can officially
I just thought I just read Dustin's
comment retro with back to back special
guests in concurrent weeks
right I mean you guys I I didn't think
we could top James expecto go
but now tonight we bring forth the
Sorting Hat
the Sorting Hat and that was the perfect
segue too I totally ruined it as soon as
you all were saying like I saw somebody
was asking uh what house are you retro
that was the perfect segue
I missed it Leviathan ax ornament oh my
gosh that sounds awesome
but uh but yeah anyway so my wife just
took it ran with it she's already got a
whole bunch of little Harry Potter
ornaments she's got she's got like the
Hogwarts crest and then she thought of
this for the topper so this will be on
top of the tree that we might have up
next week I feel like it might be a
little tall though it's three feet and
so it actually I mean let's see one two
three yeah you guys probably aren't
gonna see much of the Sorting Hat so
maybe that's maybe we that's a good
thing that I wear the Sorting Hat
and then we also need to come up with
something
we we got to come up with something fun
for when we hit
hit uh 100 likes every time I think
maybe I'll I'll always switch over to
the Sorting Hat at least for the initial
like when we hit it and then we'll
switch back to the Retro hat at some
point but um
and then I we need to do something else
too I don't have enough room for any
kind of pure reading here and that's
already James's thing I don't want to
take that I know uh I was watching
wizard PhD on her stream she does a lot
of
she has a little wheel spin and then she
does things like I saw her doing some
high kicks today also a pirate
but I thought we might do something
different like ours is like the channel
name you know retro reckon tour
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell I thought we might do
like maybe something fun with quotes
like I pick a random Harry Potter quote
and then you guys try to Name the
character and book that it's from
something like that you know
if my dog is contemplating whether she
wants back in let me see if she wants
back in
come on back
good morning
all the regulars of the stream know I
have a second webcam I should just put
like as a doggie cam but she she's
always moving like her bed is over in
that corner but then when she goes out
she's at this little door right here and
once in from there
I can't believe the game comes out in 14
weeks oh my gosh it's really only 14
weeks
asked if you were Hufflepuff because the
next person to do a gameplay showcase is
a huffle
whoa wait a second what
because the next person to do a gameplay
showcase is a Hufflepuff because the end
of the Showcase it was a Hufflepuff robe
I'm trying to cross out content creators
yo darkest demon looking way deep wait
wasn't that just James at the end
wasn't that still because James is a
Hufflepuff
and would they really go back to back
hufflepuffs right
although although
they haven't been uh they missed out on
our well we'll talk about this whole
companion situation here in a second see
this is the bad part though like the Hat
sticks up too much
it's very small first of all
so let me see if I can do this let me
see if we can get
if we can go headphones
because I can't hear the music
and can we still go hat
no it doesn't fit as is
not fit as well oh my gosh
it might fall off this way but
okay wait hold on
I might have to switch to earbuds for
the next stream
all right let's put these back here a
little bit
okay it feels a lot worse than
it looks it's
it still looks okay but it feels just
like
like if I move around too much it's
gonna fall off my head
oh man let's try to get caught up on the
comments here I know I'm behind
I just I'm just now to the uh Leviathan
ax ornament comment again zodiac that is
a great idea for an ornament though by
the way
what do you think about switch release
any intel I'm trying Chris I am trying
I've not gotten anything zero NADA zilch
about
the switch version
I've made multiple videos on it
and have tried to get them to clarify
and I haven't heard anything
which it might just be they're not ready
you know they're clearly not ready to
talk much about it yet hopefully we can
at least get a time frame on the date
soon though because I know a lot of
people are wondering
Charlie Brown tree at targeting College
still use it today nice
oh I miss Casey hold on to miss Casey
that was three minutes ago Casey I'm so
sorry
I'm triggering it again imagine having
to shower repeatedly because you get
vinegar poured all over you each time
you hit the wrong Barrel
oh surely they have some type of um
I don't know like
like magical spell or
enchantment
that will immediately remove a foul a
foul stinch such as vinegar
all right there we go there you guys
reacting to the Hat oh yeah then the
question about the switch release
decorations tour oh yeah whenever we
have the tree see I feel like I'm having
to turn really slow now
but I want to hear the music too I don't
want to take off the hat
all right I mean I don't want to take
off the headphones
but yeah Gabe whenever I have the full
tree up I will pull it in for a close-up
and we'll do uh I'll show you guys all
the ornaments on it
what do you think about the roll prompts
in game does it open the door beside it
I want to talk about that Matt yes I
haven't had I I definitely saw it
but I haven't had enough time to really
think and try to figure out what exactly
that means yet
it's Mr Moe welcome Mr Moe
should do Impressions yes absolutely oh
the little uh the quote thing
you could always speak that quote in
your Sorting Hat voice too nice J Rossi
yeah
man I gotta think of like we don't hear
the Sorting Hat talk a lot in the movies
which very sadly the voice of the
Sorting Hat passed away uh last week
Jason really likes the idea referring to
the quotes nice okay okay
nice thank you Dylan
yeah Ben snow is a Hufflepuff that's
right Jenny
yeah darkest demon I think that was
James at the end of the uh
showcase I think that was him throughout
the whole thing it was a shot in the
room of requirement I thought the ending
of the Showcase was new stuff we will
see yeah I definitely think they were
previewing what was coming up
but I do think it was still James's
character
look
I just got to the comet I just got
zodiac killing it with the comments
tonight look like you're in herbology
with the earmuffs dude that
oh my gosh
hold on
oh my gosh
that is so true okay wait I Googled
herbology earmuffs and it's actually
no I want to see
I want to see a picture of Professor
Sprout because she has like a giant
oh here we go
wait does she have earmuffs on there
it's hard to tell
wait you're not Professor sprout
okay she has earmuffs on here it's just
dude why are screenshots of movies
so tiny
there we go
long bottoms been neglecting his
earmuffs
there we go that's the look we're going
for right now guys we got our ear muffs
for the mandrakes
and then we got the uh our Wizards hat
on
what if they change the hufflepuff's
knock every week and you have to
remember a different Rhythm Harry throws
eggs at Snape Snape looks up and snarls
you dare use my own eggs against me
Potter
no don't do that on me stream don't do
that I was trying to
all you guys are talking about what if
they change okay yeah just read that one
pick a quote read it in the Sorting
Hat's voice that might be fun to try
yeah
so first live stream I've caught here in
Australia from Samantha been loving your
content yo Samantha thank you so much
dude it is amazing how Global the the
audience is here it's amazing Samantha
what time is it there in Australia right
now
is it like early morning
if we get to 200 likes we give us a
quote to get yeah yeah let's say that
let's say that if we get to 200
we're at 132 so we got a ways to go you
guys we got a ways to go 158 watching
133 likes
so we may not be able to get let's say
let's say 150 if we get it to 150.
if we can get it to 150 we'll we'll do
the quote
killing me not knowing just need to bite
the bullet and buy a PS4 Chris honestly
like that's what I've recommended to
people
I know and I get I'm always very
cautious of like
I hate saying telling people just go buy
something because I know money is
especially tight right now with
um here in the US especially with the
economy and inflation doing what it's
doing
however if you really want to play this
game we've got enough of a lead time I
would you know if you can sell some old
games trade in some games you don't have
to go buy a PS5 or series X or like
build a new pc but I definitely think
you should try to at least play it on
PS4 or Xbox One yeah
try to find a used one uh maybe you
could even borrow a friends or buy one a
used one off a friend who upgraded to a
PS5 or series X or something
because I really I really do worry about
the switch version
and I just
I say that as a I'm a switch owner my
sons love the switch I love a lot of
games on switch I play it a lot
not as much as I used to but because
I play in a lot more PS5 now but I still
do play it a lot especially when we're
traveling or on the go
um it's a great system but
I do not anticipate that it is going to
run this game well or it's going to run
off a cloud version which then it may
run better but then you have all the
deals all the issues with clout running
off the cloud
what do you think the Sorting ceremony
will be like Matt says
all cutscene or will you walk up to the
chair
I think you'll I think you'll walk up to
the chair
Oh you mean like actually in control
though because if you think about what
we have seen about the Sorting
having a drink very carefully so the Hat
doesn't fall off
I think it just feels a lot more
unsecure unsecure because it's uh
it's connected to the top of my
headphones
scourgeify oh that's right yeah yeah
at 49.59 in the gameplay showcase you
see a person going into the room of
requirement with Hufflepuff robes
ah okay that's what's darkest demons
talking about
the hat is nice hey thank you Casey
I know you meant whales watching them
playing a game
against actual whales I'd watch that no
I did not I was uh I was working during
the day today
so I did not get to watch it ended in a
tie right that's so weird to me that it
could end in a tie
it's not James's character at the very
ending of the showcase there's a
Hufflepuff running into the Menagerie
but it's not James's character ah okay
okay okay
all right all right all right let's see
here
a little more challenging I think you
all said 49.59
also like the very
wait 49 hold on
49.59 hold up hold up
there is no 49.59
right there
no not that one
right there there there oh
dude okay yes it is definitely
Hufflepuff
and they have a
yo what if that
I never thought about that what if that
was actually a tease for her the next
person is gonna be for the Showcase
can't I think that's blonde hair
dude what if it's like Tom Felton
imagine
like they switch it up like not a
content creator this time like somebody
known from the fandom
somebody uh made Popular by the the
movies but he's not a Hufflepuff is he
is he in real life
I think he's a Slytherin I think I
remember seeing that he was actually
Slytherin
I'm sure somebody in chat will know what
he actually is so yeah I know for sure
Ben is a Hufflepuff
but that like see right there it looks
like brown hair and then right when
they're running into the yeah so like a
blondish brown hair
dude I I can't believe you guys are
trying to to guess the next
uh co-host
by looking at the the Hufflepuff at the
end
so funny
Professor retro
we know it's you guys it's not me
it is not me
although if it was I couldn't say that
it wasn't but
I'm just telling you I'm telling you
it's not people were asking me in the
Discord too like I'm not under an NDA so
if it were me I'd be under an NDA
so I would have to say things like
let's see what would I have to say I
would have to say things like we'll see
or
I wonder who it will be
we'll just have to wait and find out I
would I would have to say things like
that
Tom is a Gryffindor but he chose
Slytherin yo
I thought I remembered him getting
something other than Slytherin though
he refuses to take the test so he just
says slithering uh
out of curiosity did that astronomers
hat Amazon pre-exclusive ever get
confirmed Stephen that's a great
question
I never saw anything official however it
is still on
hold on I'm gonna have to open I think I
can try an incognito was it Amazon
France
I think it was Amazon France
and maybe Germany too
oh wait it's gone I might be wrong let
me check
Amazon uh Germany
no don't change to the U.S
I'm just testing something
wait it is gone
okay Hogwarts Legacy astronomers
hat
okay wait yeah let's go to the Reddit
oh this was deleted by the person who
originally posted
it's on the French and German that's
what I thought
so wait is this gone now
they used to have they had a picture of
it over here
let me look at just the standard
Casey with another
another what is happening apparently Tom
is making it confusing I saw a video
where he got sorted in a Gryffindor JP
raven fire says they saw a video where
Tom was sorted a novel Puff what
he strikes me I mean that's why I said
Hufflepuff on the beginning I was like
I could see Tom being a Hufflepuff
foreign
people would be so mad though if if he
did it and he wasn't wearing Slytherin
robes it'd be so mad
oh wait Amazon exclusive right oh there
it is okay so it's a separate a separate
thing
and there it is I mean that looks pretty
darn official to me
pretty darn official I I think it's
strange that they haven't commented on
it officially
like Avalanche or anybody but
then again like
see that's where it gets into the like
like the stuff I just don't know about
how games and the marketing work because
Avalanche and their marketing folks are
all based here in the US yet WB of
course is global the game is going to be
shipping all over the world
so do they actually like is it more on
in wb's court to reveal that
now I gotta go back to Amazon France and
see if they have a a special thing too
and then Noob with a super chat gotta do
it every stream just a friendly reminder
to say stay hydrated and which is better
pancakes or waffles
okay I'm gonna I hope I don't make
anyone angry I love them both I'll I'll
start by saying that straight up love
them both but if you give me a choice
give me a nice Crispy Waffle
give me a nice Crispy Waffle I love
waffles so much
oh wait it is there did I just miss I
think I just I think I just missed it
before
so that one doesn't have oh maybe I was
on the wrong it does have to be this
Amazon Edition
and yeah there it is
so I mean I think it is official but I
think right now it's only for those
territories
maybe as we get closer we will
um you know the other territories will
have things confirmed
but yeah I love some waffles love some
waffles
Tom Holland is a Harry Potter Super Fan
and his voice is excitement for the game
I saw that Rhys yes
Ahmad I really think it's gonna be Ben
dude Ben would be awesome
although Ben that'd be uh Ben would be
coming from pretty far off
Retros next goes but he can't say
if I were under an NDA I don't think I
could I mean I guess I could just
straight up lie but I I'm I don't lie I
don't lie
I I would not I would never straight up
lie to you guys I truly mean that I
would
I would find ways around it but I would
never just straight up lie
and I told I straight up told you guys
I'm not under an NDA so
if if I were the next one I would I
would have to be under an NDA
Ben hasn't put out as much content
lately
oh
oh maybe Ben's been traveling a bit
Perhaps Perhaps
Ben did put out a video he had a great
video up about the like secrets and
details from the from the Showcase I'm
just gonna leave this like
unless we're talking about something
specific I'm just leaving this wait over
here
just leaving this picture of sprout over
here so people stumbling into the stream
can just be like what the heck
another Hufflepuff would be upsetting
yeah I could see them I could see them
trying to balance it out because think
about it on the actual the first live
stream they had one of each house
now are they gonna be as judicious with
that throughout because we've already
seen the ravenclaws
um in terms of the uh companion
um
not kidding as much uh attention
yeah Ben's a Hufflepuff yeah yeah
what is my ilver morning house it was
Thunder Thunderbird
is that one
I think it's Thunderbird right
over morning
houses
yeah I was Thunderbird
which is so accurate soul of the wizard
soul of the wizard Adventurer yeah yep
yep yep and I love how these aren't
perfect translations
translation it's probably not the right
word I love how they're not exactly
Gryffindor Ravenclaw Hufflepuff and
Slytherin I love how they're a little
bit different like this one sorry
ravenclaws that one is pretty yeah that
one's pretty much matches
ravenclaws but the others like heart of
the wizard healers body of the wizard
Warriors soul of the wizard adventurers
those are very different I feel like
from Gryffindor Slytherin and Hufflepuff
like maybe you could say
like maybe Gryffindor would be the
warrior
and then who would be healer or
see I feel like yeah I don't feel like
it's perfect when you get to Hufflepuff
and
Slytherin they don't really fit into
either of those two very very
neatly
how long until Nexus has a 100
completion for Hogwarts Legacy
I'm not familiar with Nexus
miles I'm under NDA about
I would not say to you guys I'm not
under an NDA I just wouldn't talk about
it
I would just I would just ignore all the
questions
see that's what I mean that's the power
of the stream you know Casey with
another Super Chat by the way
Casey showing some crazy Love Tonight
sent a 10 super chat retro should I play
as an evil Hufflepuff or good but
neutral Slytherin for my first
playthrough on PS4
ooh I mean I feel like everybody's kind
of intrigued by this idea of an evil
Hufflepuff
so I'm gonna say I'm gonna say evil
Hufflepuff
I'm gonna go with the the classic good
Gryffindor though for my first
playthrough
but I I also wonder
I don't want to say anything about
trophies because I don't for those who
don't want to know anything at all I
don't want to spill anything for you
let's just say I don't think there will
be a like
in a lot of games it's like oh you need
to play through as one way and then
there's another way for a trophy you're
not gonna have to worry about that with
this game so I think the incentive will
purely be
what happens in the story right how
different the story is that will be the
incentive for doing any replays
and changing your decisions yeah
in the trailer they mentioned the four
houses represent air Earth fire water do
you think these may play a role in a
secret common room entrance
ah secret common room entrance
I don't think they would do I don't
think they would do that because we
already have the main entrances which
they made such a big deal about and they
look so wonderful and then we have the
uh the flu flames
so I think the flu Flames will
we still don't know exactly how those
will work in the common rooms
so assuming you can only travel to ones
that you've discovered so you're not
going to be able to take
a flu Flame as a Gryffindor into
Slytherin
but I guess you will be able to be you
know in other parts of the castle and if
you're a Slytherin you know you'll be
able to oh I need to take a quick
flame right back
and then another Super Chat from Noob
which by the way last time Noob gave a
super chat I forgot to
hydrate so tonight we have a
we have a peach Waterloo
Peach Waterloo haven't had peach in a
while pumped to get it back I think
Peach is probably my favorite one
I love Peach I love grape and I love the
black cherry
and then Casey oh my goodness Casey
again
evil Hufflepuff for PS4 and good but
neutral Slytherin for a Nintendo switch
it is then yo let's go
if switch ever when the switch ever
finally comes out right
CAD Bane Bounty Hunter yes absolutely
planning a deep dive
um people in the Discord have been
sharing a lot of things that they've
been pinpoint pinpointing
and that video just takes so long to do
and I've been
I probably would have had it out if not
for this the Ravenclaw announcement
but when that happened it threw me off I
had to I had to make that video and get
that one out
oh and then noobs oh yeah I just
sorry Noob I'm getting to it poppy
Sweeting is the main villain I swear on
my back firing wand and at least half a
bottle of butter beer
I don't think so
I don't think so
but we shall see he read it calmly yeah
like
like Dumbledore was supposed to do in
Goblet of Fire you guys jeez don't you
know
don't you know
yeah but but I am um and then it's
probably gonna get pushed back further
because here here's the good thing about
I won't be able to record anything while
I'm away traveling but I will have a
laptop with me
and so I'm gonna get to do a lot of
writing I hope
so I'm gonna go through all the notes
that people have collected in the
Discord I'm going to re-watch do my full
Deep dive on my own
compile all my notes and then write
write all all the secrets and details
because there's just
there's so much in there I still don't
think we fully scratched the surface yet
still don't think we have
Chris says okay hear me out just
commented this unexpected go live video
I sadly missed have you all seen the
theory that bethilda
all right I'm gonna take credit for that
one I'm pretty sure that theory
originated with me
I'm pretty sure I'm the first one to
throw it out there
I threw it out and it got a ton of
retweets
and likes
I can't remember if I was responding to
expect a go or if I was responding to an
official Hogwarts Legacy
and I'm gonna be honest with you guys
just gonna break it down for you I'll
keep it real here
because I've I've seen this comment from
several people I don't know if that was
you and uh that might have been you
Chris in the in the actual comments on
one of my videos today because I replied
to this
I've been seeing this in a lot of
comments I would love it I think it
would be awesome
it was kind of just a crackpot Theory
though you guys it was It was kind of
just a crackpot Theory okay
it wasn't something that I had a lot of
solid evidence behind
now if it happens of course I'm claiming
it you know
but it was really more like a wouldn't
it be crazy if and the reason I said it
is because
of that field guide
so remember how when they were being all
Coy about the uh the field guy like what
is the name of this the unauthorized
guide to Hogwarts
and so then when we started learning
more about it they started showing those
tips which we now know the little tips
and secrets aren't actually in the book
that's in the game at least I don't
think they are
but I was thinking I was like oh what if
it's like
this almost sounds like Hogwarts A
History
this sounds like we're helping write
Hogwarts A History
so then I'm like okay but the back shot
of course wrote Hogwarts of History
let's check up on bethilda's timeline
now most likely bathilda is going to be
much older
I think technically she could be 17 and
be a seventh year however I think it's
more likely that she is older based on
some of the information that we know
um
even if she is older though that doesn't
ruin the theory for me
now what it ruled out would it would it
overrule her being a ravel call
Companion yes because
unless she's just like visiting the
school and then hey I'm a Ravenclaw and
we don't even know she's a Ravenclaw
that was another thing we don't know her
house she lives in godric's Hollow so
people assume godric's Hollow but hey
not everybody who lived there is from uh
not everybody's from godox Hollow is in
Gryffindor there's no way uh Rossi or is
it Rossi or Rosie I'm gonna say Rossi uh
sent a Super Chat are you worried about
performance if you look under epic games
it says the minimum expects to run the
game is a GTX 1070 which is really high
oh is that um is that also what it said
on
the steam requirements too
let me see if I can uh
Hogwarts Legacy Steam
that does seem a little hot 1070 does
seem a little high I almost wonder if
that was recommended
and not the minimum
[Music]
oh my gosh you're not kidding that's the
minimum
even on Steam so here we are on Steam
guys
uh yeah that
that does feel a little high
processor not too bad I5 8400 or the
ryzen 5 2600 which I believe that that
one's pretty old
wow that is fairly
so I have a 2060 super which I think is
like the I think it's like on par with a
1070. so I should be good but I'm going
to be playing on PS5
foreign
JP says 1070 is low got that like six
years ago JP have you been following the
the GPU situation it's getting a lot
better now but now that I mean that that
feels High to me for for a game that's
still running on PS4 like let's look up
um
I don't know let's let's find something
new and noteworthy like a top seller
what's a relatively new game
Modern Warfare 2 would that be a good
one
uh
let's look up Elden ring
Elder ring will be a good one
I was born in 1940.
not really
okay let's see here
yeah see Eldon rain 1060. three gigabyte
1060.
but then it requires more on the
processor side I'm also not like a PC
expert either so
then let's look up like uh Red Dead even
though Red Dead is a much older game
1060 for Red Dead as well on the minimum
yeah new God of War is not out yet on PC
now I wanna like Modern Warfare is
probably the biggest uh
new game so let's just check that one
by the way Knight wolf thank you so much
for subscribing to the channel and then
Jay becoming a channel member right
there Jay thank you so much for becoming
a channel member here
I know Modern Warfare is going to be low
it's GTX 960 yeah
because that game's multiplayer and they
wanna they wanna have that
hey what you know they got to be broadly
broadly appealing with that
yo we got 154. hey let's go all right so
here's what we're gonna do guys for
hitting 154 likes
I gotta make sure I took it off screen
here
okay
random Harry Potter book
quote
generator is there such a thing
all right see I can't tell you guys like
what list I'm getting it from or what
list I'm pulling it from
all right now let me see if I can pick
one that's
I want to pick something that is
not obvious this is not it but like this
no I'm not even gonna say that
all right so first
I want you guys to try and tell me
who said it
and then bonus points if you can guess
the book
so these are let me make sure I'm
correct here
I want to make sure these are book
quotes and not movie quotes
because I definitely want to stick to
the book quotes
all right here we go here we go here we
go
and I'm not I'm gonna try not to put any
inflection on it to
youth cannot change Wait I messed up
cancel that
We Go Again youth cannot know how age
thinks and feels but old men are guilty
if they forget what it was to be young
youth cannot know how age thinks and
feels but old men are guilty if they
forget what it was to be young
one more time youth cannot know how age
thinks and feels but old men are guilty
if they forget what it was to be young
no cheating right yeah yeah don't look
it up guys
durmstring is in Albania look up the
crests and you'll see
there's a Harry Potter RP form that says
the Australian school is called
I'm not even gonna try to pronounce that
but it is not canon
uh it's Mr Mo have a 1080 10i starting
to have struggles with big open world
games and like war zone also gotta think
just how big this is gonna be right so
like how is it gonna run on the switch
how's it going to run on there
by the way we have yet to talk about the
Ravenclaw companion so replay Squad
sorry guys
sorry we're gonna get there I promise
we've only been going for an hour and a
half
just an hour and a half I feel like
people are talking about weapons cars
computers or some other form of tech
when they start listening off their
specs right
oh so true open world games are more CPU
and RAM intensive than GPU interesting
as Hogwarts is requiring more on the GPU
side it seems like
all right it looks like Okay so let's
see zodiac says Dumbledore book six
Chris says Dumbledore
Mary says Dumbledore
why does it sound like a riddle from a
sphinx uh go ninja says slug horn
Supernova with the correct answer
Trevor the Toad book 16. no uh radar
says Dumbledore
Sergio says Albus in book six feather
says Dumbledore had Blood Prince Ryan
says Dumbledore Harry Potter one
uh tealside says McGonagall
one says definitely sounds like
Dumbledore Gabe says now do a backflip
Dumbledore probably maybe maybe ordered
the Phoenix after Sirius died
high IQ Warrior
uh Boneyard says sounds like Dumbledore
couldn't even begin to guess which book
haven't read them in a long time
Dumbledore book 6 chapter 37 says Hansen
edits Slytherin Pride Dumbledore book
six
Dumbledore Order of the Phoenix says
radar
all right so you guys are right it is
Dumbledore
it is Dumbledore and I think I saw two
get the book correct
now I'm wanting to double check because
we have
we had somebody literally call out a
chapter
so this website that I found is showing
that it is from book five
Harry Potter and the Order of the
Phoenix I can see why so many people
would guess
book six
now let me go let me go on Goodreads
here and Goodreads will tell us
yeah it's Order of the Phoenix so
congrats to the the two people
who got it right with book five
I think I would have guessed book six as
well
I do
and I think you were also right I bet it
was after after Siri's death yeah
Ryan We're not gonna get there any any
advice to new creators for YouTubers
oh man
I've got it pulled up over here now at
least over here
so maybe we'll get there I mean I made a
video on it but I did I did want to talk
about it a little bit too
feathers changed it before I said it
Supernova it's a conspiracy it's Trevor
Trevor
um advice to new creators for YouTube so
depends on first of all depends on where
you're like where you're at how new is
new if you're just getting started
you just have to
start thinking of it
alright so if you're asking that
question let me back up let me back up
let me back up because I always think
it's important to first consider your
goal if you're in it just to have fun
then my advice to you will be very
different than if you're in it to build
a community and possibly build a a
revenue stream for something that you
could sorry hold on I can't do this with
the Sorting Hat on
we'll bring the Sorting Hat Back
but I'm like someone's gonna clip this
dude giving advice on YouTube wearing a
Sorting Hat
and I'm like nobody's gonna take this
serious
yeah there's the there's the mouth and
eyes right there
it's like it's very subtle though
you can like just make it out a bit
I just realized how hilarious that would
look as I was
describing it there
um so yeah my advice would be very
different
and and since you're asking that
question I I would assume that you're
asking it because you
are wanting to grow a community or make
a little side income maybe even turn it
into full time
if that is
part then
start thinking of it as
a business much sooner rather than later
shifting from a hobby mindset to a
business mindset is what changed
everything for me
because instead of saying why are people
watching my videos
why isn't anybody watching
why are they what worries why isn't
anybody watching this I started saying
what value am I bringing to people
what why would they watch
why why would anybody watch this video
and it's it's it's a little tough love
saying it out loud I know it's kind of
hard to hear that
and I've I'm you know I don't know if
you're asking about you or somebody else
so it's not I'm not insulting anybody
directly but I had to say that about my
own content I was like why would anybody
watch
Nico one of the few here hanging out who
has seen my whole
kind of content creator Journey which
blows my mind Nico will bring up all
these random things from when I streamed
on Twitch to like three people
my dude
you really have been following that long
um
and so when I first started I was like
oh you know I'll stream and then I'll
then I'll just post the videos on
YouTube
why would anybody care why why would
they care about watching me play Smash
Brothers am I really great at the game
no am I doing some tips in the game no
it was just literally me playing
okay so then then I'm like okay
let's let's get a little bit bit better
at this then I did a Luigi's Mansion
let's play
I took and I really I really highly
edited it I edited that a lot
and thought okay
maybe this is a step in the right
direction I'm going for I'm going for
something funny here you know
but still like the value wasn't enough
it's like you have to give people a
clear reason to watch
you have to give them something because
and I have never taken this for granted
ever since the YouTube has kind of went
you know grown a lot
is the most valuable thing people have
a lot of people think it's money it's
not money
it's not money it's their time
it's their time
so that's why I'm always like
whenever I'm doing a live stream and I
have this many people I don't even know
how many we have watching right now
whether it's 5 50 100 150 whatever 300
last week with James we were at over 600
at one point
that is such an incredible thing to like
when I think about you have that many
people who are giving a time out of
their day to watch you
so live streams is like a whole
different ball game because that's like
a whole different level of wow you were
showing super support for the channel
I'll get your uh chat here Noob and then
Sig Sig or Psy Co Psy KO
as soon as I finish this thought
um
but but even with YouTube videos it's
the same way it's the same way you're
not even asking people for money you're
asking people to spend time over Netflix
over playing a game over all the other
channels on YouTube
you're saying hey can you watch my video
why
why why why
and so I found my why I was like I've
got to start providing value when
somebody watches this video there has to
be something that they get out of it
that's the biggest step think of it as a
business think of it as delivering value
to people then you get into the whole
thing with packaging and titles and
thumbnails which is a whole you know
that's a big part of it too because if
nobody can find it and if they're not
interested by it you could have the
greatest video in the world but if
they're not interested then they're not
going to click on it so you have to Peak
the Curiosity with the title thumbnail
and then the video just has to be like
yes you know you want them you want them
to watch it and just be
you immediately deliver on your promise
and the title in the thumbnail and then
you carry that out for the whole video
that's it there you go I can talk about
YouTube all day all day
so that that question uh got me on a
little uh a roll there all right so Noob
says now hear me out the Ravenclaw
companion is me it has been confirmed
and it's right there on the screen is
that your
wait what there it is it's Noob you guys
we missed it it was there all along
and then uh PSI KO thank you all so much
for the super chats by the way how do
you think they will handle your
character's clothing while in cutscenes
so it doesn't break the immersion I eat
regular clothes while in class
I think the cutscenes will be
I hope it will all be an engine so it
will be whatever we're wearing at the
time
most newer games are doing this now like
God of War I'm replaying the 2018 God of
War right now and so like you change the
armor out and then he's wearing that
armor in the cutscenes
so
I
man
Jake with the Emoji
how's it going Jake uh do I still play
Animal Crossing I do not know Chris so
Chris you've been watching or you
watched some of the old videos either
you've been watching for for a while or
you watching the old videos I have not
played it in a while uh my son popped in
a little bit for I don't know probably a
month or so ago
but yeah we basically did everything
like we completed our Museum we caught
all the fish we got the um
the golden fishing rod and I think we
caught all the pretty sure we caught all
the bugs too
we didn't fully complete the museum
because we didn't complete the um like
all of the the Jolly red stuff we didn't
complete that
but yeah it just got to the point where
we had seen everything so
we both kind of kind of lost uh lost
interest but man that was a fun ride
I'll never forget that I'll never forget
2020
for a lot of reasons uh but that game
you know during all the lockdowns and
stuff playing that game with my son and
star I mean that's what started the
YouTube channel guys that is when I that
is when I committed
that was the moment
Dustin it starts with care two oh nope
it did the thing where it jumps away
from the comment
whether it's one view or a thousand take
the time put honest care in your videos
The Views will come yeah I mean it's
just like
um
you just have to give people something
that
that they care about you know it sounds
so easy and I know
I know it's not
and I know to people like who are trying
to get started it's like what you know
delivering value because I heard so many
people say that so many times value
value value and I'm just like what I
feel like I'm I feel like this is
valuable
and then you almost have to become your
own I'm not going to say worst critic
because you just you got to stay
positive too but just watch your videos
okay this is a good one too watch your
videos and the second
that your mind starts to wander
Circle that time stamp because you you
need to cut something
you just have to edit relentlessly where
it's like
if you go back and watch some of my
early videos a lot of people some people
don't like
I'll be I'll be curious to see what chat
says about this one
because I know some of you still say
retro uh the dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
if you've noticed in some of my more
recent videos I've dropped saying that
and it's because I don't have an intro
at all
I don't have an intro I used to do like
the whole intro and then like Splash
screens don't worry about some big fancy
intro splash screen
but now it's like I am every of all my
videos immediately sorry and because
it's not because I don't love the saying
and it's not because I'm no longer a dad
who loves games and the stories they
tell I am
but I can look at the YouTube retention
graph and I would see where people would
skip
the vast majority of people would skip
the intro and they go right to when the
video begins and in fact the moment that
I made the change the moment that I said
all right I'm not doing them anymore I'm
not doing intros at all anymore was when
somebody they actually posted in the
comment video starts at
and they put the time stamp which people
people can you know see and they can
click that it becomes a link for my
video and they can jump to that point
and I went back and watched and sure
enough it was like
the intro ends and that's where they put
the timestamp
yeah
so that's why if any of you have watched
have been like oh why does he never say
it anymore maybe I should start saying
it in live streams that would be a good
way to keep it keep it alive still
stories they tell
but yeah it just doesn't have a place in
my YouTube videos anymore because
everyone has the attention span of like
we all do man I mean it's like our
attention spans are so
short
uh go ninja says uh I think he meant
wholesome Maybe
content with updates and funny moments
why I pop in weekly when I can yo thank
you
Professor Abbott just took the over
morning test looks like I'm a
Thunderbird welcome Abbott I'm a
Thunderbird as well
playing God of War 2 right now nice I
haven't even started the new one yet
I've still
I've still been replaying the other one
imagine in a cutscene doing normal class
stuff in dark wizard robes
like the mask and stuff
the masks that they've already teased
no zodiac I haven't yet
I'm just like
taking my time
I've taken the uh I've taken it Draven I
was the a Thunderbird that might be a
fun I I unless you mean like retake it
though we could might could retake it
Assassin's Creed keeps you in what you
put on but takes off your headpiece the
past few years
do you think they will prompt you with
the recommendation on clothing
oh like like if you're going to class
maybe you're required during classes
that might be a thing like you're
required to wear your robes for class
if it just automatically puts you in
there I could see that
oh yes uh yeah for sure Ryan for sure
Twitter's probably the best place to uh
to reach out
okay now this song I'm totally digging
it's not very Harry Potter but I'm
liking it
I'm liking it
the hustle Russell welcome back
uh oh gosh I have a 49 page handbook to
reach for my job can I go back into
being a kid so I don't want to deal with
this 49 age oh my goodness Mary
YouTube limits 500 a day that's all
500 how much
goodness
what I think of your icon and banner
Jake
uh you talk about the little Emoji in
the chat
djane is here in the house as well
welcome djane do you think we will see
the 70th potions tournament do you think
we'll be able to attend
I'm gonna say no Johnny I'm gonna say no
I know that's been a popular one popping
up lately but unless they just have kept
that like
completely quiet which I'm sure that we
don't know everything
sure we don't know everything
uh Casey would love to do pranks with
peeves yeah it's gonna be interesting to
see how peeves plays out in this game
like we saw him in the I'll see this one
wait this does not look like
I think it oh I hope that wasn't a
copyright song
I hope it wasn't a copyrighted song
because it went out of my playlist I
believe
actually let's switch to this one
it's nice to have a saying though maybe
at the end
you could put it at the end
he did it he said the thing
your channel art and icon
are you talking about on your YouTube
Jake I don't think I've looked at it
hold on let me try to uh
there you are
put user in timeout oh whoops no I
didn't I didn't
oh I was trying to just like click on
your
all right so let's see the results of
our poll here so earlier guys we asked
favorite Thanksgiving menu item turkey
ham
dressing stuffing or sides like macaroni
cheese potatoes
dude it was really close
really close by the way thank you for
another five dollar Super Chat
PSI KO again or Psy maybe it's psycho
spelled differently
how involved do you think the classmates
we meet will be
in the main story like Neville Draco
Luna Etc
well thank you for that psycho because
that is the perfect segue
into tonight's topic of discussion an
hour and 52 minutes into the Stream
we finally arrived guys we finally
arrived the results of the poll though
uh turkey and ham finished out on top
just barely 31 uh second were the sides
macaroni and cheese at 30 along with oh
oh somebody just tied it up somebody
just tied it up for the mac and cheese
and potatoes
dressing and stuffing in second place at
21 and then surprising the pumpkin pie
seventy percent
oh man I'm so hungry though I am so
hungry yeah I think if I had to pick
just one I'm I know a lot of people
don't like turkey I actually really do
like Thanksgiving turkey
my family a few years ago started
changing the way
oh it's there's something that my mom
started doing differently to where the
turkey tastes a lot better but I've
always liked turkey anyway
I remember when I when I was a kid it
was always really dry the turkey but
yeah she changed something up in the
past I don't know five ten years or so
and it's a lot better now but yeah if I
had to pick just one though I think I
would go with the with the mac and
cheese
with the mac and cheese all right so the
the comment there
from psycho
pumpkin pie lost because I didn't
include the Cool Whip no
oh wait there was another comment I just
saw from elwin
oh where did it go
oh it does not yeah it's not a Cherry
Coke tonight is uh I went with Waterloo
I don't need caffeine this late
it's a peach flavored Waterloo I'm
trying to uh
trying to cut back on the caffeine late
at night so
I don't drink any regular soda anymore
it's always a Cherry Coke Zero
but
whenever I'm drinking it this late for
stream it's just too late for the
caffeine
the one you sent in the community chat
in the Discord
uh I probably didn't see that uh Jake I
don't really check
I rarely check Discord messages
sadly
unless you're talking about posting it
in one of the um
like in one of the
channels there but I might have I might
not have seen it there
we kill people so that's why I thought
of the movies oh my gosh
Mark uh jumping in to say hello hope
everyone has a great evening great
holiday mark thank you so much for
stopping by
hope you have a great wonderful
Thanksgiving as well
Elder Wing will probably be Game of the
Year it's my game of the year right now
for sure but I haven't played uh
Ragnarok yet
I actually haven't played a ton of new
games this year I really want to play uh
Horizon as well
all right so let's let's get to this
question here about the classmates
so
I'm gonna turn off music for this
because I want to go back I was honestly
really looking forward to this chat
because I
I wanted to go back to the original
Hogwarts Legacy
state of play
and I want to listen to exactly what
they say
when they introduce the companions
so we're going to do this together
because I have a theory if you haven't
seen my video from today yet then this
will all be new to you if you have seen
it then you'll get a chance to hear me
expand on it further and get a reaction
from you guys in real time so oh well I
jumped to the perfect spot okay so I'm
gonna I'm just going to back it up five
seconds and then play it from here
I should do my herbology homework you're
despicable
place to stop abilities may be taught to
you by students who become your friends
okay
that line right there some abilities
let's turn on the captions
some abilities may be taught to you by
students who become your friends
as you develop relationships with these
schoolmates they can accompany you on
your journey as your companions okay so
they straight up called it companions
they set it right there in the text on
the the text that popped up in this
little scene they called them Companions
and they said it right there will
accompany you on your journey as
companions I'm just going to listen to
this again abilities maybe talk to you
but some abilities may be taught to you
by students who become your friends
we've seen this already with Sebastian
and crucio students who become your
friends
as you develop relationships with these
schoolmates they can accompany you on
your journey as your companions
and over time you'll learn their stories
so as they're saying this they're
showing natsai
that scene right there is a scene from
the cut scene
a scene that scene is a scene from the
the Autodesk presentation where uh
Avalanche revealed a new cutscene it was
very short but it was that was the shot
right there and we're pretty sure that
is from one of Natty's missions
and so then here they are introducing us
to them they're introducing us to the
companions that's Iona I've Adventurer
driven by the Justice she seeks puppy
Sweeting has a kind heart and loves
magical beasts connecting with them more
easily than with humans but what happens
now unafraid of detention or breaking
the rules
Sebastian sallow a charismatic Slytherin
moving over this boy horrible figs
cannot reverse a curse with a troubling
Family secret nothing can the sooner you
accept that reality the better you'll
meet these students and more you'll meet
these students
and more
okay by changing the terminology right
there to students
and more
because initially we were all like okay
and more companions and more by changing
the wording to students I think they're
just saying you'll meet more students
look here they are here's some of them
as you explore common rooms hallways
between classes and regular Gathering
areas and I think
well okay yeah that's it all right
okay so they introduced us to the three
companions
and so obviously
we're all immediately gonna think oh
where's Ravenclaw right I mean that's
the natural reaction you get Gryffindor
you get Hufflepuff you get Slytherin
where's Ravenclaw and they told us
straight up right there I'd forgotten
I'd actually forgotten that they spelled
it out there
so clearly and it is also still almost
word for word what we just heard in that
trailer right there is almost word for
word what they still have here in the
FAQ will players establish friendships
in Hogwarts Legacy and then they say
some students at Hogwarts will become
friends as players grow these
relationships these schoolmates will
become companions who can accompany
players on their Journeys expand their
abilities and open up as players learn
their stories yeah that's almost exactly
what they said in the trailer here
almost exactly
so they gave us right then and there
the definition of a companion a
companion is someone who we're going to
learn abilities from them so that's one
component they're going to have a story
and they're also going to be able to
accompany us on our journey
now
I'll be honest with you guys it never in
a million years would I think they
wouldn't have a Ravenclaw companion
never I mean it just it just didn't make
any sense to me like why why would you
not
we've been fortunate enough to talk to
people occasionally
a few little tidbits that we've gotten
behind the scenes we broke the story on
quidditch
um and there was a couple other things
as well but then one of the other things
was
I heard there was Ravenclaw companion
and I I told people that so I want to be
clear about this this character right
here that we were introduced to I
believe it's pronounced omit
the car
not the car the car I think
um this is the one I knew about
this is the one I knew about I believe
he is of uh Indian descent
and that is what I knew I did not know
the name but I knew that was a male
Indian Ravenclaw is what I knew
so there's not in terms of companion
anything that I may or may not have
heard this was it so there's at least
from what I know there's nothing more
like it's not like there's something
else coming or about to get revealed
about
Ravenclaw
now here's where things start to get
interesting
this was November 18th
you will meet many classmates from
Gryffindor Slytherin Hufflepuff and yes
even Ravenclaw so there they go using
the classmates terminology now the
astronomy loving emit is just one of
those classmates
all right we can bring the music back
now because it just feels too quiet
without it
and then here's what it says about him
amid aspires to be a famous Wizarding
historian and already has extensive
plans for his first Memoir exceptionally
bright and well read you know no
surprise for Ravenclaw here he adores
stargazing and always seems to have the
most recent top of the line telescope at
hand amid will leap at the chance to
help a friend in need but once in the
thick of things often realizes he might
be better off reading or writing about
certain Adventures than experiencing
them so 100 percent
I feel like this is Chandler and
Hogwarts Legacy of the marketing like
this is them saying
here's the Ravenclaw
not companion
they've got the card though
they've got the card that looks just
like
let me pull them all up here because I
have them all saved
uh actually hold on it might be faster
no I want to pull them all up at once
so we can look at all all four of them
at the same time
all right so that's in the official here
okay so we've got emit
we've got Nat's eye
we've got Poppy
and we've got
Sebastian
okay so clearly
by revealing him in this way
they're attempting to position him as
the Ravenclaw equivalent
of these four
wow that was a terrible job spacing all
these out hold on
oh Poppy
all right sorry somebody's gonna have to
be
slightly hidden
unless we take them all just a wee bit
smaller
so the cards all look like exactly the
same right I mean clearly there that's
what they're trying to show here
they're trying to show that these are
the four
companions
but that's not what they say
that's not what they say
so it's one thing for the Hogwarts
Legacy tweet okay you know that's
maybe they just they they talked about
them being classmates in the video that
we just watched as well
but that was only one component
then we also have
our boy Finch Strife AKA Chandler Wood
Community manager for the game
and then he provides some additional
context here
excited to introduce you to just one
more of your
classmates
Seb Natty Poppy
he doesn't stop there Nelly Zenobia
Lucan Amit and more will all play a role
in your journey as you attend Hogwarts
I think that that tweet is the one that
made people more
starting to kind of read in
to what really may be happening here
I know it's going to upset people I
heard you I heard James say it in his
stream today
I don't think they have a Ravenclaw
companion
at least not in the sense that Nat's eye
Poppy and Sebastian are companions but
what I will also say
is I think they are doing away with
the companion terminology I think
they're doing away with it
and I'm going to show you this why as
well if you've already seen my video
this will be a repeat but I haven't seen
a lot of people talking about this shout
out to uh Alicia by the way I don't know
if Alicia is still here hanging out in
the Stream but Alicia is the one who
caught this
and posted it in the um
I'm gonna meet this again posted it in
our Discord
um oh wow it's actually pretty close to
this right here I think it was around
yeah right here 33.
yeah I didn't see a lot of people
talking about so this is Lucan so Luke
and Brad will be I thought he was a
first year I think they just said in a
younger year they don't confirm what
year so
we just know that he's younger than
fifth
um so maybe not a first year but he's
younger than our character
and he is one of those that Chandler
just mentioned as well as uh who was the
other one uh Nelly and then Zenobia also
characters that we met as giving us side
quests in this gameplay showcase now
Chandler is putting those characters in
the same category as Poppy nassai and
Sebastian as well as Amit who we have
seen like only thing we've gotten on him
is the card and I'm gonna get your
comments I know I see I see a lot a lot
of you guys got thoughts I see him
coming in I'm gonna get to them but let
me let me get to this part here so in
this scene here
of course he's the one who heads up the
cross wants watch this right here watch
this this pops up Quest complete Spell
combination practice and then right here
challenge unlocked complete side
slash relationship quests
and so when I saw this
when I saw this right here pop up after
Lucan gives us this little mission
I immediately thought they're doing away
with companions with that word
companions
why
we
we can we can get into the why
um
I think the big question is and I've
seen I know feathers left a comment on
the video today and some of you other
ravenclaws as well
I think the big question is
I mean what we're all wanting to know is
like did Ravenclaw Get Enough Love Like
did Ravenclaw get forgotten is a myth
going to be
as fun of a character even if you don't
like amidst like backstory or whatever
but but is he gonna have a character
with as much uh screen time for lack of
a better word as the others now another
thing to keep in mind we know the quests
from like Sebastian got his own trailer
right but we know that is entirely
optional we know that is optional
which then we know that Nat size is
optional and to be fair we haven't
gotten confirmation on the poppy like if
like what her quests would look like
either
we've seen a little bit from Mass Eye a
lot from Sebastian the the bit that we
saw from natsai was from the the
Autodesk presentation
so then we've got this complete side
relationship Quest and then this part
kind of confuses me because watch this
this pops up and then it pops up again
complete side slash relationship quests
one of two so I'm like wait why did it
pop up a second time okay so you're
unlocking it and then all right then you
complete the first step of it so is it a
side quest or is a relationship Quest
I saw some of the people commenting on
that right because it said side slash
relationship
so I think they're doing away with the
terminology of companion and I think
they're just I think they're going to
call everything
um you know classmates and they're gonna
say they're gonna talk about
relationships
another thing Sebastian and natsai pop
up as options right there there they are
to join us in the crossed ones duel
so does that mean we haven't met Papa
yet is she not part of the
the group just yet did we not do her
side quests because we know the side
quests are optional
and then what level like where does omit
fall in all of that
that's the biggest question for me
that's the biggest question
um so for those of you who were hoping
that maybe I would have because I told
people I I've heard there's a Ravenclaw
companion for anybody who was hoping
that I was going to be able to say oh
this is not it guys there's another one
that I've heard about
it's not this is the one omit is the one
so I guess
for the ravenclaws out there
what would make you guys
like what how could he be I guess what
I'm trying to ask is how could he not be
a companion that joins us
and that can be you know fighting
alongside us
what else could he do to elevate him
enough to where he would still be seen
in your eyes as like oh they still gave
gave Ravenclaw love it's not like they
just forgot about us he had something
else fun to do now let me get to your
let me get to your comments
let me scroll up here it's gonna take me
a bit to catch up
and I'm not gonna be able to go back and
get all of them but
uh JP mini classmates and other NPCs can
become companions feather says that's so
flipping unfair uh Casey says it would
have been interesting to see Hermione
arguing with ravenclaw's door knocker to
be left because it's mad she answers The
Riddles correctly
uh Ryan they have it's now referred to
as relationships
I think so Ryan yeah I think so
imagine you can have all of them join
you on and by the way guys I know
there's some trophy stuff here as well
I'm gonna I talk about that briefly at
the end of the video that I put out
today but we're gonna try try not to
talk about the trophy stuff even though
I this one's very minor I know it's not
a huge it's not like a big story spoiler
but some people don't want to know
anything about the trophies at all so
try try not to bring that that piece of
it up because I know there's an element
of that to consider here as well uh Noob
said imagine you can have all of them
join you on adventures and you can just
storm a poacher base with like 20 other
kids
it's funny you say that
it's funny you say that noob
I'm gonna come back to that don't let me
don't let me forget that I'm gonna come
back to that from the first trailer
um Ultra Blue says trying to soften the
blow possibly even make us forget the
work of pain it's not close blow black
it might be right Ultra Blue
I think you might be right
that being said I do think
that's kind of why I'm asking that
question like what else could they give
a mitt or could could admit do that
would Elevate him to the point of like
oh this is just as cool it's different
he's not joining us in this battle but
this is just as cool and it's Unique to
his his character like they already talk
in the card about how he's like you know
he's going to help out his friends but
then he also realizes like oh
I'm better off on the sidelines in some
things there's the complete relationship
quests popping up again
um after they completed that section
there JP pretty sure Lucan is his third
year uh Josh think you're right have
companions fight alongside you or
joining us was hard to flesh out so they
changed to helping or meeting classmates
with their side quests yeah I think amid
to be clear I think he's gonna have side
quests and I think we're gonna learn his
story I do
I don't know that I think he's gonna be
one that will join us and unlock
abilities
why couldn't they take out for both Jake
says sorry James oh my gosh
better get a rainbow called DLC feather
says
and see that's the other crazy thing
like like Alan and Moira they're both
ravenclaws this one just like it blows
it will blow my mind if there's not
I mean I hope we're all wrong like I
hope James and I are wrong on this and
anybody else who's kind of
speculating in in this realm or I hope
that yes Amit is is a different type of
he's a different type of student to
where he's not he's not the companion
like we learned about right there but he
is still
an interesting character who's going to
have a major part to play in the story
what if it's like the companions in
Hogwarts mystery uh explain that a
little bit further Ahmad how exactly do
they work there they need to add
quidditch in this uh maybe in a DLC
maybe in a DLC
saw that in Ben's video very interesting
I think Dustin was talking about the the
menu option at least let us go watch the
games because of the characters in the
Quidditch troops that I could see
happening Casey I could see us having at
least at least like a cut scene Maybe
in the Showcase they never say what um
they don't say lucan's house or his year
I went and looked specifically Alan says
um in fact I'll show you how I I did it
really cool trick on YouTube guys this
three little dots you can do show
transcript
and then if you do control F or command
F on a map a Mac
so it they have to have set this up like
if you do it on mine YouTube Auto
generates a lot of mine because I don't
have time to or the money to pay for the
all the official so Alan says here we'll
just go and listen to it right here
he just says Lucan is in a younger a
younger year because I initially thought
he said first year
definitely know about it but they think
they're being clever and it's run by
this Luke and Brad will be here who's in
a younger year but we kind of like that
this that he's running things
so that was Alan Luke and Brad will be
let's see uh what does he say here
yeah Alan so Chandler says and it's run
by this Lucan bradleby here Alan then
jumps in and says who's in a younger
year but we kind of like this you know
that he's running things and then they
go into the cutscene here I don't think
they ever say his actual
year though
I don't think so but yeah because I some
people commented that after I said first
year in my video and I was like
I thought he said first year but yeah he
does not say first year all right so he
says uh younger year
unless there's another part maybe
there's another part
I just realized I've been in the Stream
for two hours just realized it
no playable quidditch uh right right
right
yo another 10 gifted memberships fire
tea
fire tea I didn't even know you were
here hanging out tonight
how are you thank you so much fire tea
and those of you who just got a gifted
make sure you think fire for the gift
and membership let's see if it actually
works for all of you how are you welcome
to Gryffindor welcome to Gryffindor
uh let's see they just said he was
younger didn't say here right right
right guessing third they did say
Zenobia was first year right I think I
probably just yeah I think that's what
happened is I'm like oh younger year
first year
how are you welcome to Griffin Ryan says
relationships means companions
yeah I think that's the term they have
used to replace companion is they're
just going to call them relationships
now but they were all they will be of
varying
degrees
some of the relationships will be
characters who we learn this full back
story on and they teach us new abilities
and they have quests and they have
they can actually join us on our journey
those were the ones formerly known as
companions then
we have all these other characters who
are also important but they're not
companion like
um the the three there The Big Three
do you think we can earn companions on
the outside of Hogwarts
I don't think so but that would be
awesome if he could
and then then we get to the other thing
like is fig a companion because we see
fig he's obviously not a student Cabana
but we have seen the shot of fig
fighting alongside us
as well as Centaur so it's like
I would I would consider that a
companion personally like if we have a
if we have any Quests for them and they
fight alongside us
I think that's a companion so maybe
we're gonna have like adult companions
too but then again maybe fig only joins
us for part of it uh Mary says actually
someone pointed out that we see Amit
somewhere in one of the trailers and was
put in the Discord people keep saying
that Mary I don't think I don't think
it's a myth
I do not think it's him
I think it looks totally different I'm
with Sue on that they were talking about
that James and Sue were talking about
that during their stream as well
uh B Barbie I think a bit will help us
finding the ancient pensive so it's not
necessary to come with us but it would
still be a major role
that's what I'm thinking along the lines
of me Barbie that's exactly what I'm
thinking I think he's gonna have a
different
significant hopefully significant role
to play
L when there is no way there wasn't a
rainbow called capina from the start it
would be the biggest PR nightmare today
I agree with you on that for sure
to alienate a fourth of the Hogwarts
Legacy fans I think we'll have a bunch
of classmates with quests challenges but
campaigns will be able to go with us
that's the difference yeah that's kind
of ultimately how I'm seeing the
difference too
because I think we're gonna have a lot
of quest givers
but then it's like Lucan and Zenobia
like I don't think they are
I don't think they're com there see we
gotta be like do we keep using the term
or not I don't think they're compete I'm
gonna keep saying companions until they
say officially one way or the other
because right now it's just speculation
for me based on
going into that trailer and seeing oh
they're calling this Quest relationships
rather than companions
feathers like I just want some
representation I'll take that over
quidditch any or anything any day
like see they've been so good about
making sure
making sure everybody feels included and
like it's it's your story be The Witcher
wizard you want to be
if you're a Ravenclaw student it would
just be so strange for me if you don't
have like your your companion you know
I'm with you Elwyn like I I'm still
shocked by it
but I
that's still the way I'm leaning that's
still the way I'm leaning is that I
don't think there is a
I don't think there's a Nat side Poppy
Sebastian equivalent for Ravenclaw
which is it it really is mind-blowing to
me it's mind-blowing
but so my hope is that Amit he may not
join us but he's going to have some
other important role to play whether
maybe his missions are required
maybe whatever you're doing with him is
required
and then another oh wait JP this is
early in the game so we haven't gotten
Poppy's a follower yet yeah I could see
that
haven't met Amit yet but we see him
during the Showcase
now you guys are saying we see him in
the Showcase too
oh when there is nothing about emit that
would point to why they held back his
story there is going to be a Ravenclaw
companion that is important to the story
they can't release the info yet due to
spoilers oh
see that's been the big thing for a
while a lot of people have been saying
is like there's something from Ravenclaw
coming
but they can't say too much because
it's important to the story I have like
sorry I keep rubbing this side of my
face because
I don't know if it's like an eyelash or
something
that keeps like Crossing in front of my
vision
uh Ryan says as I said I think emit is
like Rowan in Hogwarts mystery oh see
I'm not familiar with that but I've
heard there's like a big twist or
something with Rowan uh Chris I think
it's a teaser historian who else is a
historian
uh Mary we keep going to him for
research is my opinion yeah I think it's
I think it's going to be something more
like that
uh Johnny says retro NASA in this video
in effect every student have three black
stripes on the sleeves yet in other
videos natsai has three red lines in
every other
Josh says he does your over
um
the three lines so there are differences
in
the robes
and I think that they could even change
throughout the game and other characters
maybe they you know they could change
robes like our character but then the
other thing I will say is they have also
changed some things from trailer to
trailer
there are things that have changed ever
so slightly
Nico says companion would need story
significance
yeah I think for Ray yeah for ravenclaws
to be happy the quest line is needed
Rossi that's the feeling I get two ultra
I don't like the fact that he's a
younger Lockhart I ain't getting
obliviated or reputation nicked
oh a younger Lockhart
I don't know I feel like he's
I feel like he's gonna be legit
I think he's going to be legitimately
like a smart dude
and not not trying to like
trick anybody
unless there's like a big story twist
serious question though do we know what
house Professor fig is in maybe he is
our quote-unquote Ravenclaw companion
that had been another theory for a while
Nico I don't think we know his house
which now that I mention it I don't
think we know the Ravenclaw
because we know for sure that
oh geez the Slytherin
uh Professor Abraham Ronan is the
Slytherin
head of house
I don't think we know the other heads of
house
but yeah I could see fig being a
Ravenclaw
if the companions are only important for
their side quests and not the main story
then it'll be very disappointing
because see they are optional they are
optional that's an important
that's a good point psycho we know that
they're optional which I I like that
they're optional but then maybe they do
have some other impact in the main story
as well
uh uppercase Logan hey retro is there
any new info about the dark souls-esque
roll
we see in this day to play any
speculation about what that really is
timestamp is 709
yeah we just we just passed that
didn't we
or wait no I think we're getting
foreign
I think we're getting I think we're
coming up on it
we're coming up on it actually
uh Rhys I think the only three that are
going to have a fleshed out ending
altering the line of quest for the
original Three we've seen already
everyone else will be fetch Quest hence
Amit is not going on a quest with us
I I question the part about
oh
I don't know how much nasai Poppy and
Sebastian will affect the the main story
because they're optional
they're optional
Jason may be story and learning and
ability or something
having an old
feathers having an old dude be the
Ravenclaw Cabana would be such a dumb
thing all right here we're coming up on
the roll
oh wait wasn't that it right there or no
I think it's
it might be at the top here
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
first off what even is that over here
what even is that
it's like we can see a question mark
right there
I'll leave that on that shot for a
second see what you guys think about
that
Noob oh did I miss
oh my goodness I missed I'm so sorry
you're a wizard how did I miss these I
missed the two super chats
from psycho
excuse me and Noob my apologies guys so
psycho said RPGs 10 plus years ago they
have way more than four right yeah even
um
I mean I'm thinking like Persona you
know you end up having way more than
four which is set in a similar
similar type of setting and then Noob
you could see just more
then fight with us he could
he could
JP quit comparing admit to Lockhart amid
actually does his own work not taking
credit yeah I think so I think so
he helps you study for your owls Josh
says admit better be really amazing if
he's all we get helps with puzzle type
quests
that is interesting Hannah
that is interesting I like that and I
could see that
Natasha what if Sebastian's sister is
the Ravenclaw companion and they threw
amid out there to try to keep her Secret
Ah that's been some somewhat of a theory
too we do see his sister I kind of think
his sister's not even going to school
though I think
either she has like a private lesson
or she's just not able to go to school
because of her ailment
Casey I want a dating relationship as
well man I made a video on like that and
a long time ago and it's funny people
get really uh
people could really hated about that one
for some reason I think they could do it
in like a fun cute you know
kid kind of way but I I don't think
they're I don't think they're gonna do
it
the more that the more that time has
passed and the more I think about it but
yeah I have a video about that on the
channel called um I think it's like
romance in Hogwarts Legacy that one's
still like more than any other video
like old video like that that one still
gets comments that will pop up of people
like
course it could totally work and then be
people being like I can't believe you
would suggest such a thing 15 year olds
and romance
my guys what kind of romance you talking
about here okay what kind of romance
you're talking about because that's not
what I'm talking about
we're talking about like you have a fun
little side quest where you go to Madame
putty foots together okay
jeez
haven't you guys played Persona you like
unlock you know the more you build your
relationship sort of like what Hogwarts
Legacy was talking about like you you
build a relationship you get special
abilities with that character
uh Brittany connections to Merlin
somehow would make this game uh this guy
awesome of admit was connected yeah it
would uh Jay Rossi I mean it's smart but
maybe it prefers reading studying to
fighting yeah exactly researcher or
healer would be an interesting role for
a minute to have
uh help us in the main story healer was
something that just became interesting
okay why are the alerts dying
because I just saw
wait did fire tea gift another tin
why did that just now pop up over here
fire tea thank you so much for the
gifteds I don't think I miss them but if
I did I'm so very sorry and uh yeah 10
of you got a gifted membership there
from fire tea that was 14 minutes ago so
I don't think I missed it
Alicia with a super chat Alicia thank
you so much feel bad for muting you
so why you got me on mute what what
Alicia
I thought we were friends why do you
have me on mute here
it's all good Alicia thank you for being
here supporting the stream thank you for
the Super Chat as well uh Hanson what's
the big deal with no companions
realistically they're just NPCs that
will shoot people for you like the
little kid and God of War they don't
need to be super fleshed out best
friends Imo
uh I mean that's one way of looking at
it I'm guessing you're not a Ravenclaw
that's one way of looking at it
JP I think each of the companions have a
particular fighting style seven Neti
might be more up close poppy in a minute
would be more likely to hang back
I like that idea oh oh wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
what if admit
is the one who helps us with
the other things we can do in battle
like it talked about him in astronomy
though right stargazing I was gonna say
like what if he's one who's really good
at potions he helps us Brew the potions
that we're going to use in the
battlefield or uh like growing the
mandrakes and stuff which we know you
can use on the battlefield as well
uh Jay Ross C maybe while the others go
with us and it could be someone will
return to after mission that's that's
sort of what I'm thinking unlocks things
for us and Chronicles the journey maybe
he teaches us more than helps us maybe
he's the guy in the chair
not sure what chair
Nico I'm thinking two things right now
what a professor figs the rainbow called
companion or Amit is the companion but
he helps you throughout the story with
information
like so yeah like maybe the ravenclaws
actually get kind of two companions you
get like fig as the one who gets to go
out and do stuff and then you get a MIT
as more like kind of the behind the
scenes planner
oh man
uh excuse me do you think they used him
not liking Adventure as a reason to not
have him as a companion no
I think that would have been a
convenient
piece of his story to add like after the
fact though I can't imagine you sit down
on the drawing board and say hey we want
these four uh all right we got these
four characters we're gonna put them in
this house and then we don't we're not
going to worry about anything for
Ravenclaw
that would just be so surprising
Johnny says anyone with a three color
house stripes in their sleeves will be
companions I think oh interesting idea I
haven't looked that in detail on the
three stripes
Casey catch me over here being a death
puff in my game my girlfriend's trying
her hardest to help me not get expelled
psycho with another Super Chat uh do you
think if our level is skill
skills bare high enough it unlocks
different dialogue options because
you're proficient at it
I love the idea and I've seen that in
games before
I'm thinking no
I'm thinking no
so podcast now in his uh
if we want to come back to this by the
way I haven't seen any comments yet
about it it could be possible that I'm
just so far behind
I mean when I first saw this I thought
it's I thought it's talking about roll
like I think it's talking about
something on that little question mark
display like you're gonna spin something
what I have no idea I have no idea
that's that's my guess though
uh so podcast now and James did a live
stream
last week late last week
and I think more so than any other look
at Hogwarts Legacy so far this gameplay
showcase look right here
really started to give us a look at the
fabric of the game
what do I mean by that like like how
it's built like like the systems in the
game how they're actually going to work
I think it gave us the the closest look
yet because a lot of times speculation's
been running wild and and I've always
told people like yeah we still don't
even really know
what the parameters are even for this
game all we knew was open world action
RPG that was it man there are many many
many different types of open world
action RPG
and so we're slowly starting to get more
pieces to that puzzle
and what kind of like the restraints are
on the game and I don't mean that in a
bad way because every video game has
restraints every single one right there
are restraints to the world and how it
works
and so like that question right there
uh from psycho about do I think it
unlocks different dialogue options I
don't think so because
I don't think they're I don't think the
game has the systems in place for all
these multiple dialogue options I think
the dialogue is going to be
I think you'll have some key moments in
the story
where you have to make
a significant choice
like we've seen with with like Sebastian
and then the learning of the crew of
crucial and all that
that will we obviously know that one has
a big role because it's going to
determine hey whether or not you get
this spell or not right
if you choose no then I don't guess you
get to learn it we don't know for sure
yet how that's going to shake out
but yeah in terms of like having all a
lot of different dialogue that's like
that's one of the systems I just I'd be
shocked I'd like that though I would
Alicia says we are friends I was busy
please forgive
Alicia you know it's all good I'm just
giving you a hard time
thank you for your support Alicia as
always
okay it will be stupid if you have just
three companions that can join you in
your journey because it will not be your
journey anymore you cannot choose who
will be your friend
I mean I ca I'm gonna keep saying it
guys I'd be shocked
I would really be surprised even though
I shouldn't say I'd be surprised because
that's what I'm predicting now
um I'm shocked though I am I'm still
shocked
because that is just
I just can't imagine that they wouldn't
have something
significant enough
for ravenclaws as well
and if they don't I love I love to get
an interview with one of the anybody
after the fact to figuring out the why
because I think I know the answer
I think
and this is like no inside information
or anything this is not me
this is just pure speculation
like I feel like when when you're
writing the game I bet if I had to if I
had to guess on this I don't think they
started out with natsai poppy and
Sebastian and immediately said this is
what house they're in
I could be wrong maybe that is where
they started which
that's where they started then I'm like
why didn't you do the same for Ravenclaw
my guess is that they had oh wait you
think that's a mitt right there was that
him walking by
wait let's rewind this
oh the hair the hair works
look right here on the right
dude and he's carrying something too
what is he carrying
and then what is that like is that a
giant feather
wait there's a quill
it's like a quill and a tablet oh dude
what if that's actually him
somebody did say he appears in this oh
wait we're gonna get a full view let's
see spin around does it show him
oh no he's already walked by has he
already walked by oh they're not gonna
turn all the way around
okay wait that that wasn't him
oh there he is now he's turning that way
no
come on Andrew
come on
but yeah I'd love I I feel like it would
be more a writing thing like you start
writing and you got this great character
right and so you start fleshing out
their backstory and then you start
writing okay this is a cool Quest they
could do and then you're like okay which
house are they I feel like the house
would come like in the middle of the
process rather than at the at the very
beginning
and then it's like okay you already got
this great character we can turn them
into this companion and then you're like
okay what other characters do we have
but even even then like even as I'm
saying it
if you knew you didn't have one for
Ravenclaw that was like in the same kind
of realm in the same category wouldn't
you add wouldn't you add one
feels super excluded if there's less
Ravenclaw content
oh lots of lots of new uh members there
with that gifted and then shadowing in
the house 10 Subs let's go
I think that was actually uh yeah
memberships here and then I did see
we've had a new a few new Subs pop in as
well
uh Ultra Blue right there's nothing
pointing to why they held a mint story
back not unless they're hiding bigger
story points but still it feels like
they're telling us Ravenclaw it's not
cool at all
and the other thing is I don't think
Chandler has responded to anybody
you know Chandler's really good about
usually responding to a couple comments
from people who ask questions like for
follow-up and clarification a lot of
people were hitting him up for
clarification on that any and he didn't
say anything
he didn't say anything
but maybe he will we'll see fire tea saw
that you were streaming decided to give
membership instead of donating this time
fire tea thank you so much my friend man
you guys are just showing crazy love and
support tonight here on this rare Monday
edition of retro rack into her live
thank you so much again fire tea Logan
says retro is there any new info about
the oh yeah oh my gosh I'm so far behind
that comment was forever ago
still here trying to design a companion
card thing for my own official character
nice Phantom draws
is Deke a companion like C that he could
be
he could be
Phantom draws gotta go a have a good
night Phantom draws thank you for being
here
sassy sis what's up I see the Gryffindor
emoji
fire T get alert have an amazing stream
fire T thanks so much
uh Draco or Draco I still don't want to
be friends with a Hufflepuff Gryffindor
or Ravenclaw just give me two Slytherin
companions
oh lee retro don't be offended I need to
say you have a maze
is that a meme or something what the
heck how do you can you see my eyes from
can you actually see my eyes
I don't even care if it's a joke I'm
gonna thank you I'm gonna thank you for
that and why would I be why would it be
offended
thank you very much
yeah I have uh blue eyes blue eyes if
you can see them from the in this little
window then you have good eyes yourself
to be able to see that
so the Ravenclaw classmate right chicken
right I think so Theo says Chandler just
trolling with us it's companion he just
wants something for us to talk about
Chandler doesn't strike me as
I could see how he would have some fun
trolling but I he doesn't strike me as
one who would troll the community like
that in that way he he trolls the
community by pointing out the the owls
in the trailer and talking about James
being the Merlin
um conspiracy theorist I feel like he
trolls in that way when it comes to like
the actual news for the game which I
gotta say ever since Chandler has been
there we we have a heads up almost just
about every single time before like we
never have to wonder is Hogwarts like is
he gonna be here they almost always tell
us in advance
ex I think the only one that was a
surprise might have been Gamescom
now the gameplay showcase this one they
only gave us like a one day notice which
was so annoying to me because I had a
big work thing but um
yeah but they usually do a pretty good
job of like kind of just you know
keeping it level with you and being like
this is what's happening
I don't think he Patrol the community
like that because he knows they've been
asking for Ravenclaw
talking about seeing emits oh it just
did that thing
where it jumps and Skips a bunch of
comments whenever it does that what it
tells me is that I'm really far behind
that's what it tells me is that I'm so
far behind
oh my gosh you guys I'm just now seeing
this these
I gotta go through these quickly
yeah no problem Casey
oh my gosh I'm so far behind
skylines what's up welcome
oh my gosh I'm so I repeat I'm so far
behind
I still I'm scrolling back and I'm still
oh my gosh you guys I'm so sorry I gotta
come up with a better way of doing like
you guys just make such comments and I
want to talk about them
and then I'm just I'm just so far
okay I'm only making it worse I'm only
I'm only making it worse by stopping and
talking
okay there we go I finally got back to
Logan's all right so let's go quick
let's go quick
uh recess I think it's just character
they threw out there to troll if it was
their fourth companion they would have
shown it back in March uh Chris says
true it seems like he follows even less
popular characters like the owls comment
and the gameplay was adding wife once a
wizard right right right uh JP says
retro look at 26 26. oh we're actually
coming up on that
I'm just gonna put it right there before
I
stop it a little bit before
all right now I'm not gonna say I'm not
gonna make this video go forward until
I'm fully caught up on comments uh
Hanson I think uh it's part of this
weird Trend they're doing
a lot of students hang out between
houses which didn't really happen much
in the books or movies oh
I think the difference is that natsai
and Company have see I can't I can't do
all of you guys thoughts so if you're
leaving a good comment apologies for
just passing quickly I have to get
caught up
I think the difference is the NASA
company have story quests you can
achieve wife wants a wizard is hilarious
I'll agreed agreed
bathilda I'm sold
hope they're holding someone really cool
back for ravenclaws
who gives students the puberty talk if
they hit early Hogwarts in their pants
whoever can't sell them head of house
prefix head boy head girl I will let you
guys speculate on that one uh if it's my
story I don't want a Ravenclaw for a
companion I want friends who are in my
house with me
well I mean they're optional we know the
three are optional
the three that we know about think about
Rowan and Hogwarts Mysteries he is your
best friend from the start
Timothy ninja what's up Timothy welcome
Myrtle isn't alive yet so no indeed
no Hannah we do not officially know
bathilda's house that was a
a crackpot theory that I think I'm the
one who started
Maybe I'm Wrong Roman is supposed to be
the best friend but they're in like
hardly any of the story Quests for most
of it uh be stupid if you only just have
three companions you can join in your
journey not be your journey anymore
Timothy I just got here and I'm very
lost so am I Timothy I'm a million
comments behind
uh yeah late 1800s like around 1890.
which
I'm not even sure if it's 1890 anymore
you guys
I'm not even sure if it's 1890 anymore
I'm wondering if they've changed that
I wonder if they've changed that because
of a comment that Troy Levitt made on
Twitter
feel emit is not as interesting as
compelling
Nancy popular Sebastian to be honest
I would say we don't know enough he
could be
he could be we just don't know enough
yet
wait what have you been wondering
oh the bear
uh there isn't a game out there allows
you to interact him if you're in every
NPC true true true
Ultra says agree he doesn't feel that
special uh Nico I think we see the
character with natsai and hogs means
spying on Rookwood and ran Rock maybe
that was part of the main story
could be
yeah no problem Johnny
think the third person in the dark magic
character you mean the trailer is a
Ravenclaw classmate
I feel like the button will open some
kind of hidden door behind that face see
goodness gracious oh the roll button
yeah
yeah
like 30 minutes ago I'm so behind
chamber secrets on my brother's GameCube
oh that's where I played it too love
that game
when they talk about companions do they
mean that the character storyline is
optional but they may still come with
you on your storyline regardless if you
do theirs
foreign
my interpretation has always been yes
like today if you do their Quest I mean
that's how it is in other RPGs right you
you kind of get to choose like your
party like who's coming with me for this
especially in turn-based games like if
you can only have three at a time or
whatever you choose the party that
you're going in with
think them being optional be a perfect
example of completing or not completing
their Quest changing outcomes I've made
missions and endings
cyberpunk had tons of optional missions
that alter the main story
don't really want to be followed around
too much they could have a date but not
more oh my gosh I'm so far behind
they're not getting married or anything
exactly teens that age due date so
exactly exactly Rossi exactly right
oh my gosh you guys like everybody that
I'm replying to
they're already gone they're like I sent
this comment an hour ago
Mary I'm tempted to make a video about
how amid is able to help us on missions
if he's not for combat
that'd be a good one
that would be a good one maybe just
going to a winter dance and going right
like a dance like oh a dance would be so
cool in this game that could be like a
major story moment happening there
poppy could be a Healer
you think Seb sister is like Ariana
Dumbledore ain't allowed out of the
house due to how dangerous she could be
could be
I think it's a blood maledictus is my
guess
had a kid at 16 a girl who's 15 so yeah
romance happens people it's an artist
whoa
nah poppy only heals animal
hope emit would be more than just
Hogwarts
Clippy I don't know what that is
what if a mitt teaches us how to use
pincips I like that one
I like that one high IQ
the romance is like what it is in
Hogwarts mystery it could work without
going too far for fifth year students
all right I'm getting close shooting
stars at enemies as a Hufflepuff who
wants to get a ton of magical creatures
I don't mind only having three
companions
join slytherins save the world can we
get an animal pet that can go true water
into the water
I don't think so the closer we get I
don't think we can go underwater game
releases close to Valentine's Day so
romance for the dancing Cupid memes
please maybe mint is one of those who
sends us the owl post I can see that Jay
Rossi what if the real Ravenclaw could
be
was the friends along the way amid as
the brains of the operation 79 days
right Miles Morales it's crazy crazy
roll for a chance don't with a deadly
aloe
I love that idea I don't think so psycho
oh wait what did psycho say
oh yeah the dialogue thing oh my gosh
I'm okay hold on
the house point containers are indeed
beautiful poppy is 100 Hufflepuff yep
Reese says the answer is simple
repetitive backstory probably couldn't
think of more than three completely
unique backstorys for sidecares
I'd find that hard to believe they got a
lot of uh they got a lot of
people on their team
Andrew purposely turned the camera there
to avoid I I was wondering that yeah
be nice if this game had the option to
play with three people cross platform
yeah it's just like
sadly
sadly no multiplayer some people are
happy by that though it's you know
single player only
Theory from elwin we have to have
oh it is like I saw L wouldn't expect a
ghost stream today too oh what is like
all in on this like they're there has to
be a Ravenclaw convenient in the movies
a student could be brought into a common
room that wasn't their own by a student
of the house Luna with Harry needed in
the diadem that's how we unlock those
flu places in the common rooms ah could
be and then you could still go into the
other common rooms
Maybe
Dustin if Eric God if aragog if a mitt
was in The Forbidden force with aragog
would he be a friend of Hagrid's work
oh no
just when I was about to get caught
caught up on the comments that one broke
me
oh my gosh
oh my goodness
I might have to tweet that Dustin
I might have to tweet that one if a mitt
was in The Forbidden Forest with Eric
will he be a friend
of Hagrid's Orca companion
and would he let us go or would he not
deny his children fresh meat
oh my gosh
Ultra Blue nice to see you have a good
night
I'm I'm on I'm literally screenshotting
this with my phone right now
I'm screenshotting it right now Dustin
Channel recently did post something on
Twitter
about the game I saw his post from
earlier about uh
oh yeah this is not uh this is not
Hogwarts related though
this is about everybody if if Twitter if
Twitter ceases to exist a lot of people
are trying out a platform called hive
that's what that one's about
okay I gotta get caught up here
gotta get caught up I just need to do
what James does like James just you know
if I'm if you if you miss him sorry
oh geez
all right
I'm gonna skip ahead I'm gonna skip
ahead
oh that Clippy
yes feathers of course of course
all right guys I gave up I just had to
scroll down to the bottom
so I'm I'm I'm caught up now I just
didn't get to read all the comments
Dustin has won today's live stream
indeed basilisk in the Forbidden Forest
scaring the crap out of aragog
UE yeah exactly Ryan it jumped again it
jumped on me
I was trying to to catch up on
everything
okay so I said I wasn't going to
play this because somebody said I think
26-26
oh
hey dude he took off running too
I mean
I can see it
I can see it
trying to see where we get the best look
where the face isn't blurry honestly
it's probably right there dude they like
make eye contact for a second too
he's like
I'm the rainbow Hall I'm the Ravel Club
companion dude
did you know
oh yeah you nailed it Ryan it jumped
ahead and I'm just like that's it I'm
done
I returned to the present I'm out of the
past now
I'm no longer in the past
you had this discussion with game with
James and Sue
agree it's not him well James was saying
that he looked similar to
the Ravenclaw from the uh
original trailer
I mean I think this looks closer than I
don't think it's him though
now the other one the one outside that
we never got a good look at now let's
see is the hair parted on the same
on the same side
nah that's not him
the hair is parted to the same side
though look at that
now one other quick thing I want to talk
about
this is going way back to one of noob's
comments
true not highlighted
Caroline been comparing the picture of
it and that the guy 26 26 yeah that's
that's that's where I was right there
yeah it's it's hard like skin tones are
so hard to read especially on
because I'm pretty sure Amit is supposed
to be Indian
but then like based on the brightness of
your screen and all that
okay so I wanted to look at the initial
um reveal trailer this is something Noob
said a while ago in a joking way about
all of the how many companions can join
us oh goodness I mean to have sound
it's actually toward the very
very end
it's the scene where the dragon okay
this scene right here
this one you have to really go frame by
frame to even see it
there's a moment here
when we're trying if we're trying to
figure out how many companions can join
us at once now the other part of this is
you don't know if it's a cut scene or
not
but like so let's say there's a scene
where going in we're fighting this
Dragon here
or maybe we're trying to help this
Dragon here because it looks like it's
all
restrained at the moment so look we got
this character right here
and then I'm just gonna let it play so
that's one
we see another character right here with
one of those masks on
so that's a second character two then we
see a third character
dude this guy is balding right here is
that me
this is this this definitely looks like
an older guy though
so now the other question is this one of
the poachers
are these like the bad guys
or
I mean because these two could be
but we definitely see we see three right
here
because I think that's another question
we don't know the answer to yet is how
many will be able to join us at a given
time right we just don't know
CJ do I think the Patronus charm might
be featured I really hope so
I really hope so
Nick says they they Panic picked a
random NPC to be the Ravenclaw campaign
and when they saw the community getting
riled up
I can see how it would feel that way I
do but I don't think so so the one that
I have heard about
I would even say months ago guys I don't
remember how how far I publicly shared
it with everyone and said hey
I've heard there is a Ravenclaw
companion
um but it's been several months that I
knew about it and they told me
that it was someone of Indian it was a
male Indian Ravenclaw
and so that
so I don't think they just pulled this
one out of thin air I think he's been
there from the beginning but I do still
think there's a big question about
whether or not
how big his role is I do
why would we be facing them if they were
helping us
bottle was in the game before James oh
my gosh what is this guy wearing though
right like he almost looks like a
like it looks like to me it looks like
some kind of Handler for this for this
Dragon I feel like these guys are on the
bad side but he's wearing he's wearing
one of those skull masks but then we
also know that our character let me play
it a little bit more and then this one's
got like red and this was like they
don't look anything like School robes
either
and now this character kind of turns to
face him
yeah and then it cuts away so that's all
we see but then we get another
that's a Ravenclaw right there
okay so right here this is that same
Ravenclaw that we just saw I don't think
it's a myth though
how many are with us out here now
I think we just see him I think we just
see this character right here
and then he Dives out of the way
I thought we might see another one right
there so yeah we just see three in that
scene before
right here we see three
oh there's a there's a better look at
this guy right here
foreign
that's me I'm claiming it
I'm claiming it
they put me in the game long ago guys
he doesn't oh wait does he have a beard
oh if he has a beard I'm gonna lose it
if he has a beard I'm gonna lose it oh
he might dude he might actually have a
beard we we can't see because he's
wearing the mask no I don't want that to
pop up
oh
we can't see if he has a beard but you
know what
we can't see that he doesn't have a
beard either
he looks like he's wearing the the
beaked one
that looks like a beard to me
oh man
I almost think his clothing looks
different
right here
then like casparatego to block all of
the debris I think his clothing looks
different right here
Okay so we've got like I don't know like
a grayish or blue right here and then a
black
I mean no it's definitely the same
character I think it's just a weird
lighting thing
how it looks different
and then his hit his head looks totally
different too
where dude this trailer's been out
forever and we're just way over
analyzing this I'm sure but
so yeah when uh when Noob said that
about the about companions like how many
it made me think about that scene right
there where we see at least three but
then again we don't know if that's
we don't really know if that's
us or if that's someone else
no such thing as over analyzing right
right
oh man all right guys we have officially
crossed the three hour mark
I still I still have wanted to go
through this whole thing with you guys
on the live stream we haven't been able
to do that yet
oh it's been out for a while or well too
wheat this is the second week last week
we had James on which was great
um but yeah man we So for anybody who
missed the stream and hops into the
replay and it's like dude retro streamed
early uh so I'm gonna be out of town for
the holidays for the Thanksgiving
holiday
not anything else guys stop the
speculation I'm gonna be away uh away
from my computer and everything well
I'll have my laptop with me but I won't
have my editing computer with me so I
wanted to do it tonight and make sure we
did a live stream
three hours gone I know right that was
crazy I can't believe we've been over
three hours now that's including like
the countdown the 10 minute countdown
and everything but
honestly like I'm trying to cut down
stream times like I feel like two hours
is a good a good amount I need to start
bringing a little more structure to them
I feel like but I just love I just love
going down the rabbit holes with you
guys with the chat seeing where we end
up
I just love seeing where we end up
uh maybe zenobius Ravenclaw companion
we know we get quests from her
182 yo let's go
Hanson stream as long as you want man I
would stream all night but
sadly haven't have another work day
ahead of me another work day ahead of me
and I know I keep saying it I I def I
still want to do more gameplay live
streams as well I just can't quite
figure out what I want to
I can't quite figure out
what how and when
because I know it's a different vibe man
like like here we're just hanging out
I'm just Chad is way more active but
when it's games it's a little bit
different so
hit me up on Twitter if you have any
games you'd like to see me live stream
at retroacting tour if you don't have
Twitter leave a comment on a um leave a
comment on a video
I try to I try to catch most of those
love how they said everyone in the game
has their own unique names I mean right
we see it we see it like how it pops up
above above their heads it's awesome
go ninja says that wasn't a rabbit hole
that was a four takes into another
dimension Chris so glad I finally got to
come to my first live stream hey I'm
glad as well so yeah stay tuned guys for
the uh the ASMR we will probably get
that
James is guessing tomorrow or Friday
they might do it on Black Friday but
that's like such a big shopping day in
the U.S
I'm gonna predict tomorrow
I predict tomorrow
James has the Intel after all uh he has
some Intel for sure
I don't think he would have said he
would say
If he if he wasn't supposed to say
though he he wouldn't say
Jenny thinks tomorrow
could be later today right yeah we're
getting close to uh midnight here my
time as well new with another Super Chat
to close us out stay hydrated here I'll
send poppy after you hey I've got like
I've got a little drop left
that's officially it
that's officially all of the Waterloo
Noob thank you so much thank you guys
all over here hanging out tonight for
the love the support a lot of new people
in here tonight too so guys we'd
normally do this thing every Tuesday
around 8 8 30. I have two young kids so
I just have to coordinate with my wife's
work schedule
and that that's really what controls the
time
um I would honestly prefer earlier uh
like I love the time that James does his
and I know a lot of my overseas friends
especially in the UK
hate the times that I live stream so
shout out to you guys in the replay
Squad especially if you made it this far
thank you so much
um but yeah I'm working on a man if we
can ever go full time with this uh with
this YouTube thing
we'll be streaming we'll be streaming
definitely better hours than this that's
for sure
all right guys uh if you're in the US I
hope you all have a wonderful
Thanksgiving
and then Casey one of our newcomers
there Casey with a two dollar Super Chat
on the way out
Casey thank you so much for the crazy
support tonight hope you enjoyed the
chat and enjoyed the live stream
good night to you as well
it worked yeah it went through that time
Ravenclaw Tyrell I see you in the house
but yeah guys if you want to continue
conversation with a lot of the people
that have been hanging out here in the
chat tonight I saw Nico post the Discord
there oh oh oh oh oh before we go before
we go before we go I forgot to
always feel weird plugging merch but I'm
proud of this so I shall plug it
just in time for all the holiday
shopping
we just brought out some new designs
today
I've had these for a while you guys may
recognize these
if you rock
if you're a member here the little uh
emojis that we have in the chat
they match these
so we've got the lion here on the maroon
we've got the snake here on the green
we've got the eagle on the blue and then
we've got the badger on the yellow here
I love these dude I've got to get mine
hasn't came in yet of course gonna get a
Gryffindor one so I can rock here on
stream there also are t-shirt versions
of these as well
and right now if your channel member you
get a discount all the time with a
special code but all week long we are
going to have this code going right here
15 off use the code thanks
and then we also still have our order of
Merlin merch which I I never made a
version of that in a hoodie or
sweatshirt or long sleeve
I might need to add that then we got our
unforgivable curses that is also in a
t-shirt as well
and then we have the Wizards chess club
so
no Wizard's chests and Hogwarts Legacy
but
you can be a member of the Wizards chess
club
rocking this hoodie or I think I did it
as a t-shirt as well so yeah uh just go
to retrorecontour.com and then click on
merch that's the that's the fastest way
to get there
but yeah man
um like I said check out the Discord you
can stay tuned uh stay tuned stay in
touch with a lot of the community there
I don't post in there a lot because I'm
just like I gotta get in the habit of
using Discord a little bit more
maybe it's my age I don't know I'm just
not I haven't been much of a Discord
person but Noob not Noob um Nico has
slowly been getting me
getting me to use it more and I mean
it's I like it in a lot of ways I'm
still kind of an old school like I love
the layout of old school message boards
like how you can really like you got
this topic and then you make a thread on
that topic and then anything relating to
that it's like you can see it in the
thread
whereas Discord I feel like it's too
easy to miss things and I know they
recently added some kind of thread
feature but we haven't really
experimented with that yet but anyway
I'll be about and around and um
on social media throughout I'm gonna be
doing a lot of work on the break doing
um getting that video ready because I
know everybody's wanting to see my full
breakdown of this gameplay showcase
because there was so much I also want to
do a full combat breakdown video as well
because there was so so much here on the
combat more than we've gotten ever
everything we knew about the combat
that is is smaller than what we got out
of it here in this video so that one's
coming soon as well
I do make other types of videos as well
it's not just Hogwarts Legacy but right
now the Hogwarts sexy news cyclists so
hot and there's so much happening I just
have to stay on stay on those videos
enjoy the chocolate frog discussion last
time Discord is better than Twitter
about anything is Discord is huge in the
MMO world like I I loved using Discord
for chat with some people when I played
a lot of Destiny 2 but
it's so weird to get
in the habit of like using it for
discussion like it's just too easy to
miss things
too easy
Chris huff and puff too old for that sub
right I know it does kind of feel like a
get off my lawn moment for me
does kind of feel like I get off my lawn
moment all right guys thank you all so
much for hanging out I hope you all had
a wonderful evening and hope you all
have a fantastic rest of your week uh
and I will talk to you again soon thank
you all so much for being here
foreign